okay chair you're now live
thank you very much tom uh good evening
everyone
uh watching this either on youtube or
through the
council uh zoom meeting numbers
uh welcome to this evening's a meeting
of the external overview and scrutiny
committee
um dated for the 20th of january and to
start at 6pm
um do i need to read out a list or can
you remind me of anything i need to read
out before i start
the meeting either mary or tom about
protocols
to be honest chair i think you've done
it enough times now i think so as well
so i just guided by you to make sure
we're meeting all
safety requirements okay thank you we
come then to
go through the agenda and we're starting
with
apologies for absence agenda item number
one
mary can you go through the list and
apologies um i don't know vicki
i think he's here now as well which is
good um what i'd like to do is is just
go through
the the list for apologies for
abstinence and we all introduce
ourselves
um who are attending this evening i
don't see any members of the public here
um
is there any public speakers uh tom
that'll come like no tonight
no okay so if we do the circuit to take
apologies for answer
absence um for our three
speakers who have kindly come up this
evening to present to us vicky uh claire
and
darren um i'd like the committee to
introduce themselves as we go around and
then also
michael and phil hackett the lead
members for homelessness
and health and well-being so mary can
you conduct
the apologies for absence please yes
church
and no apologies you're right
right then go through that's right mary
go through the committee and just a word
from each member from
what they represent and what their
interests are so that our
speakers know where each member is
coming from basically
councillor honkin
hello i'm councillor cheryl corto hunkin
ward member for great torrington vice
chair of the committee
and lead member for community culture
and leisure
thank you thank you
councillor ford
councillor ford you're neutral i've just
unmuted you want to say that again
please
yeah okay thanks very much yeah cancer
forward epidural ward
uh just some member of the scrutiny
thank you
thank you council harding
yeah good evening um councillor steve
harding um
heartland ward um and
a new uh relatively new um counselor so
i'm still
learning and i'm very interested in
everything
thank you thank you councillor hawking
hi yeah yeah councillor hawkins uh biddy
for town council
and george district council uh again i'm
fairly new to this as well
thank you thank you
councillor langford hello uh councillor
shirley langford
uh representing biddeford south ward
thank you councillor mckenzie
good evening uh yeah jeremy mckenzie
billy felice you
councilman newton simon newton
and i represent winkley ward
thank you council penny john yeah phil
pennington i'm the chair of the
committee
and very honored to do so i have a long
history of working in the third
sector um i was with the citizens of ice
bureau as vikki you will know your
citizens advice
um and i'm very keen to
learn more about what can be done so
thank you for the speakers this evening
my background basically was agriculture
but i represent i used to be
bitter but i'm now monkey and putford
which is
the edge of the rewards around the
district so that's me
um can we have kaiser hackett and
councillors
we've got council of leather as well
councillor chris leather um
and i'm the lead member for waste
recycling and street cleaning as well
brilliant thank you very much indeed
it's phil topham there
before i go to councillor hackett and
councillor
uh clark i'm here hello
yeah thank you very much phil i'm the
independent non-elected member on this
committee
thank you phil coaster hackett
not member of the committee but a lead
member yes
um i'm currently lead member for health
and well-being
before my new title is ratified by full
council
and i represent
broad heath ward thank you
and councillor clark yes i am
councillor clark i am two rivers and
three moore's walled which is out high
bitington dalton way
i lead council for housing options
homelessness gypsy and travellers
i'm also um i was
the league of mercy secretary in the
salvation army
and i've been dealing with homelessness
for about 20 odd years
so that's me okay um we have also
councillor claire hodgson who is
observing claire do you just want to say
hello this evening
yes fine thank you i'm claire hodson
i'm deputy leader of the council i
represent
the award of westwood ho and
i am lead member for finance and audit
thank you and we have stacey our head of
legal
and janet williams our environmental
officers will you just say hello
and introduce yourselves as well please
hello yes i'm my name's stacy dory i'm
the head of legal and governance
at torridge and i form part of the
senior management team
good evening i'm janet williams i'm the
uh public health and housing manager
and i'm part of the operational
management team
brilliant so that i think is all the
counselors and officers the most
important ones not spoken as mary as
who takes all the minutes and guides us
for what we say et cetera et cetera
so um that's i think all the counselors
side
um and the covers uh the apologies which
we have none then on
item number one i'm looking items number
two
and number three the minutes and the
action list on your agenda
and i'd like your permission council if
we could
to defer them till after we've had our
presentation
and the lead members updates of lebanon
12 so that they would come then after
um the lead members updates of
agenda items 11 and 12. would you agree
as a committee that
we could defer that as we have uh three
good speakers we would like to listen to
to start with so we can ask some
questions
does anybody object can i just see if
there's any hands going up
i am going to take a vote on this uh
stacy have hi
good job no sure no i don't see any
hands so i take it we're all in
agreement we can
um park item two and item three for the
time being and come back to the later
stage
we come to agenda item four which is
public participation
is there any speakers tom on public
participation
now none so that covers item four
item number five is declarations of
interest
um you all know the routine counselors
um
and if it comes to a point um at the
time please make your declarations of
interest known
agenda item number six agreements
between agenda items part one and
part two i have no part two um
so that one is covered i have no agenda
item number seven
urgent matters brought forward with the
permission of the chair
i have none i will allow anybody who
thinks something is urgent that's not
coming up just to make a brief comment
if there is
and i see no hands going up so we
have dealt with urgent matters
now we come to the exciting part and i
want to thank our three
presenters who are going to come with us
this evening now to to
bring us first of all ttvs then torch
north david mid devon west devon
citizens of vice
and encompass and that's darren hill
vicki rowe and claire fisher
um i take it or are with us at the time
um what i would like to do committee so
that we can get
the best um sustenance from the meeting
is each uh presenter present for
a few minutes and uh and if there is
specific questions because you
all as a committee all had the various
uh
printouts from the various organizations
and at the end of each presentation
brief presentation
um any questions that arise that are
specific to that organization we will
take them
so we'll go to eight and the gen item
nine and number ten
in the same way and then i would like to
have a
a roam table discussion if we can
possibly do it by zoom it's gonna be a
new experience for me
as well um to to try and have a around
with the aim of how we can best help the
residents of torridge when we come
through this dreadful pandemic that
we're going through at the present
moment
um and and come to terms with both the
social
welfare and community aspects to
to bring the best for our residents so
if you see where i'm coming from i would
like first of all
to invite darren hill from ttvs
to do his presentation darren thank you
for coming this evening
and um do you want to take questions are
you going through or
questions just at the end of your
presentation relating specifically
specifically to your presentation
um good evening chair um firstly thank
you very much for the opportunity to
speak about ttvs and the work that we're
doing today
i'm happy to do um either i'm happy to
take questions as we go along
as long as you can um somebody can get a
word in edge race uh with me
but uh more than happy to take questions
either specific to my presentation
or quite general in relation to the
activity we do at the end i'm really
easy with that all right thank you for
that we'll take it that uh
you fire away and if there's a question
comes up i will get a blue hand and
i will um get the necessary
uh question to ask the question fire
away sir
smashing so um thank you very much so i
thought what i would do
my presentation i'm going to speed
through it because i know that that time
is
is tight and questions are probably more
important so
for those that of you that don't know i
thought i'd just give a quick whiz
through
ttvs and what we are as an organization
um so we're a registered charity
um that has been um operating in toys
for over 30 years now
i'm a relative newcomer i landed um in
december
2019 and boy what a first year
um probably like no other um but just
if you look at the first page of my
presentation um i can just show you the
layout quickly of
our organization um so i'm answerable to
a board of trustees
and then i've split my organization into
into four areas
so we have our core staff which look
after the heart of our activity
including the volunteering and the
volunteer center that's placed in
bridgeland street biddeford then i have
my community teams who are community
developers who are out there in each of
our communities
working with them to ensure that um they
are
thriving and and capable communities
and also we employ social prescribers so
they're funded through
our pcns work within the gp surgeries
and they take a holistic view to um
to individuals who may not have a
clinical
issue but but certainly have um
concerns that we can address outside of
that
that clinical venue um we run a number
of projects uh they're predominantly
caring projects carewise
looks after young child carers um from
the age of eight up to sixteen
and bright futures looks after young
adult carers
that's from 16 to 24.
predominantly these are individuals who
are caring for somebody in their family
who may be extremely ill have profound
disabilities
and what we see is that in in order to
care for
a member of their family they lose a
number of the opportunities that many of
us take for granted
whether that be socializing whether that
be education
they just aren't able to participate in
life in the way that
some of us were lucky enough to so our
projects help put support
and guidance and try and get them to a
good place with plenty of peer support
there
we also run projects around financial
inclusion which is making sure that
people are entitled to
particularly older people entitled to
all the financial help that they can
get and certainly in biddeford alone
over the last 12 months
one member of staff has been responsible
for
bringing in over a quarter of a million
pounds worth of additional benefits to
members of our community and then under
our tour age banner we look after older
members of our community
again in a caring capacity looking after
people with bespoke
responses to their needs through a help
at home service
and also we run a number of memory and
dementia cafes
helping to support families who are
dealing with the dreadful
disease of dementia and also a new um
area for us is employment skills
and this is to complement a lot of the
other work that's going on around tour
age
at torrage sorry um so we look at
working
import in partnership with petroc and
dwp
to place people into volunteering
opportunities within organizations to
help build up skills
and cv to to make them as best places we
possibly can
to enter the work environment so
a real quick whistle stop tour through
ttvs and who we are
so the next slide is just a couple of
key points that i just want to make to
set the scene for those who don't know
too much about us so as i said
we're a registered charity and a company
limited by guarantee
we've been in existence for over 30
years and we currently
employ 26 members of staff and have 511
registered volunteers now those figures
are a snapshot
and they move they move quite frequently
and we gain and lose members of staff as
projects come and go and registered
volunteers again
we try and keep our books as update as
possible so
we know who we can call them accurately
and again
that will fluctuate we saw that rise
significantly at the start of the first
lockdown
and we've seen that drop away again as
we've gone through the year
um we have members currently we have 41
member organizations
that pay a subscription to us that's
something that i'm reviewing at the
moment
i'm looking at changing and the offer
that we we make to
our member organizations um but really
importantly the support that we give
out to small charities community groups
is not conditional on being a member
and that's something that's really
important that's something that i'm
really going to be pushing over the next
12 months um as a charity we're almost
wholly reliant on grant funding and
donation
we have a very small income stream
through a help at home service and tour
age but we're reliant on other people
supporting us to do what we can do
um i'm i'm really proud of the fact that
um
using 2020 as an example we were serving
our communities
365 days in the year we didn't close for
a single day
not through the lockdown not through the
christmas period we'd be there for for
people who need us
and then the final thing um i just want
to kind of put it out there it's really
important
um at the heart of everything we do is
volunteering it's really important
but volunteering isn't free um it comes
at a cost
um and that may be through recruitment
coordination the governance trading
supervision
management certainly expenses but whilst
we've got an amazing bank of volunteers
that do a fantastic amount of work it
does there is a cost
in order to enable that to work to
happen
so if you go on to the next slide please
say you know a guide was i think ten
minutes four minutes to go if you can
focus the high points i think our
counselors probably read
the everything before we came to the
meeting but uh just
as a guy okay yeah no that that's
absolutely fine so the next slide tells
you what we did and i think that really
speaks for itself
um the number of telephone inquiries
that we had we were part of a cascade
system through biddeford town council
and um through torridge district council
as well at our peak we had 900
volunteers that we were providing
governance for
and we um supported people throughout
the covered lockdowns with shopping
prescriptions befriending
um and quite some unique things as well
we we helped um
somebody get emergency teeth extractions
we had emergency sharpie work put in
place
um and we in one occasion uh replaced
the fridge um for somebody
so we had over 504 unique interventions
during that period of time and
we were incredibly busy and that was a
seven day a week during the first
proper lockdown seven day a week um
resource um for us
so some of the themes on the next um
slide that we've seen
we've definitely seen an increase in
mental health particularly with our
younger cohort we've had some critical
incidents
um this year um where the lockdown has
just caused
too many um issues and concerns
loneliness is a huge
um issue for us at the moment across all
age groups
which is impacted by the rural isolation
that we find many of our communities and
many of the individuals in them
and this goes across all our projects as
well but a point i want to make is that
actually we've experienced all of this
internally with our own staff
and the way that we've had to work so
we've flipped really well into working
remotely
and supporting our communities from from
outside of the office
but actually we've all felt loneliness
and isolation and
and internally welfare is something that
i'm i'm looking at and taking really
seriously with our staff um we've
learned that digital inclusion is
not a magic bullet i want to make a
point here that um particularly
with some of our younger cohort we found
from feedback to them that using
zoom and teams to keep in touch is
actually reminding them that they
they don't have the opportunity to hug
and touch and be with their friends
so it's actually created a bigger
barrier than we that we actually
um think so that's sort of something
that i just wanted to
to make people aware of and recruitment
as we've advertised for post we've
actually been inundated with with
applicants
which gives us a real snapshot of the
state of the market at the moment and
the unemployment
that's out there so the final slide for
me i just kind of leave that the
challenges that we
face as an organization going into 2021
sadly um and i don't really want to be
too glib about it but it's all about the
money
um we um are looking at finding funding
for our core activity
to supplement the existing activity that
comes in just to sort of keep doing what
we do
um we've seen some of our funding
particularly around the community
developers that's due to end
in march and we're working really hard
to try and plug the gap on that
but it's uh it's a real
concern that we may not be able to do in
2021 what we did in 2020
um and all our projects our projects are
there because there's a gap there's a
gap in that provision there's a gap in
the service in our communities
and we plug that gap the projects aren't
there because we want them there the
projects are there because we need them
and again um some of those are coming to
the end of their funding streams
this year and there's a great deal of
work in partnership that we're doing
with many of our partners
um throughout torridge and devon to to
try and
sustain uh exactly what we do but as i
said
it may be a bit glib to say it but i'll
finish again um
our challenges um all relate to finance
as i'm sure they do in every
organization up and down the country at
this point in time
um that's my whistle stop talk thank you
what a superb ten minutes thank you very
much indeed for that
um any questions specifically to darren
ttds well i
oh shirley's got a blue hand up surely
thank you very much um uh yes and thank
you ever so much for
all the amazing work you're doing and
everything um
and your team um i was just going to ask
uh particularly to ttvs
uh because um i'm also a bit of a town
councillor and at the time when the
lockdowns came in and everything
i felt very strongly there were a lot of
counselors very anxious that we should
be
doing things and everything in the
community quite rightly but i felt very
strongly that we shouldn't reinvent the
wheel and if there were volunteers
out there already functioning then we
should put a lot of our effort into
supporting
those systems to make sure that they uh
could function properly and and do the
jobs we needed doing
i just really asking how how did it go i
mean how
how have you found it in lockdown and
all the extra pressures on you how did
it
how did it go at the start of lockdown
actually putting things in place etc
thank you that um that's a really good
question so two things fell into my
favor
fell into my lap really the first is
that there was some already some
excellent systems in place
and through ttvs in relation to the the
volunteer cohort and and the links that
we had into them
but kind of having landed in the role um
i
if you you don't know my background as a
retired senior
police officer so crisis management was
something that i really felt quite
comfortable with
um running a charity perhaps not so so
um for once i actually felt my comfort
zone when we had to deal with that so i
was able to put a lot of my
my old experience um to work and build
on the great capital that had been left
to me by my predecessor
so the the biggest challenge for us
really was moving everybody remotely
um because we we didn't have the ability
to do that and actually our telephone
system was quite antiquated
and we couldn't even forward some
numbers to to mobile numbers
so the first thing that i did is had to
go out and invest in laptops and mobile
phones to make sure
every member of staff was able to work
from wherever they were sitting
so we did that quite quickly and and we
made it work
um you know we sort of stumbled through
that first lockdown
um once i came out of that lockdown i
moved us
away from land lines onto teams and
office 365
so now all our communication is on
laptops and mobile phones
so we are now a a really mobile
and um and flexible organization so that
the subsequent lockdowns have been
um quite easy for us to manage thank you
any further questions for darren ttvs
yes sorry simon
dan thank you for your brief summary um
sitting on another uh committee recently
where we are going through the whole
process of
uh this year's or next year's budget uh
etc
and we were touching on uh the grant
that uh you get from torridge briefly
um in that whilst not
wanting detail now um
is it possible that we can see your
headline
figures um the the good cries in your
presentation which are which are
excellent and they're informative etc
but
to have real meaning we need to know
the figures as well we need to know
because we don't understand
what um
our contribution represents
to you what proportion um
etc so when we are actually
having to inevitably challenge uh
all the money we give to everybody uh
we need to have an idea as to um
how what proportion and how important
and how critical etc that that money is
so it would be helpful to us darren at
some point in the future
if we can actually see your headline
figures
if necessary confidentially if that is a
requirement
yeah absolutely um i'm i'm more than
happy to
share what we have to to make that
process i mean
in simple terms the the funding that
we've received from um
from tdc has gone into our call which
has enabled our volunteer center our
volunteer network and and
the the the capability of that function
which was essential as we went into
lockdown one
but actually to break down what that
means i can do that i can do that in a
document and if we could possibly have a
conversation added here
tell me exactly what you want i can
deliver that that really isn't a problem
at all
thank you no other hands okay you've got
two hands counselor call honking and
counseling
let me get another screen up here yeah
apologize yes
christopher connolly honking you were
first and cursing another second
character um we've got a couple of
questions
the first one specific to the project um
the exercise for mental health project
came to an end in january 2020
i didn't know if there was anything
replacing it and how much funding is
required for that project
and secondly in your report you talked
about raising the profile of ttvs
um i didn't know how we could help to do
that as a council whether it's through
social media or if you've got other
ideas
for us to help that okay so exercise for
mental health um that isn't a
particularly um expensive project to run
so the member of staff that that ran
that project for us
uh has subsequently moved on um it's a
really valued member of staff and it was
a real shame to lose her
but we we have um we have kept it going
in a virtual
sense in that it's still there um
virtually and it's still offering some
guidance and support um i can't put the
exact figure on it
it is a ridiculously small amount and
it's something that we could kind of
resurrect in a heartbeat
um if we needed to and i'd happily have
a look at that
um but unfortunately that's one of those
small projects that ended
just as i landed and kind of fell off
the radar for me really over the last
year and
so the the second uh part about raising
the profile i mean i've been kind of
plugging away at that all year so um
we've now
managed to have a new and updated
website uh we've only had that for about
a month so i've been
kind of using that as a platform um we
are now
on on twitter and facebook and we use
that and
certainly we've had a lot of success on
facebook not so much on twitter it's
been very hard to get traction on that
um i think what we lack as an
organization
and and what i've been trying and
thought i've got there twice and then
sort of failed
is is having someone just to help me
with the messaging and getting those
messages out
um because it's actually quite time
consuming to make sure that that it goes
out appropriately to the right audience
um and we do it on an ad hoc basis
there's about three of us who kind of
will dip in and dip out of it
but there's no consistency and i
struggle with the consistency
so i've looked on a number of occasions
for volunteers
to come in on the basis that we will
train them up to be
a digital media manager we'll give them
the tools the equipment and
and we'll pay for training courses if
they can provide that service for us but
unfortunately even with some really
juicy carrots being dangled we we've
struggled to
um to attract somebody willing to
willing to do that and i don't know why
is is the simple answer so um
i'm willing that you know that's an open
offer right there to
um to equip and to train somebody
willing to to do that with us
um but um other than that
um it's just a case of perseverance i
think
do you want to come back cheryl um yeah
i was just wondering if um
mark crocker might be able to share some
of
the ttvs stuff i don't know if he
already does on our
tdc social media page
um he might be a good one to contact
contact there for you
darren i've written it down thank you
okay
kirsten leather thank you chair well my
question really
follows on from councillor newton it's
the money as
darren's final slide and it's there in
front of us it's all about the money
and if you look at the final page in the
report that we had sent round to us
there's a huge list of supporters
funders and partners
but what i'd like to do is what what's
the budget that you're working to for
this current financial year darren
so the the budget for this um current
financial year is
um has been delayed um we're about two
weeks off um signing that off
so it's very um difficult for me to say
at the moment but
it's it's not too far removed from last
year's and that was about 550
000 pounds um in total um
okay thank you
that's all i wanted to ask that you got
your answer chrysler leather you're
happy with that okay i see no other blue
hands
um for darren the president for ttvs
darren thank you for your presentations
answering the questions this is
so succinctly and i hope
you'll hang on as we go and um go
through the other two
presentations and come back to a
roundtable discussion in a moment
so we go then number nine uh which is
torridge north devon mid and west devon
citizen's advice
i do declare a personal interest i
worked
with the organization for some time and
i am the coach
tbc's linked member to to
this organization so that's where my
position is
and i welcome a lady called vickie rowe
and um and know vicky very well um
and ask her to bring her presentation
slides you've had before you
vicki over to you thank you for coming
this evening
okay
hello oh that's great so that's lovely
uh sorry i was i was muted for a second
thank you and very much councillor
penton for
the introduction and it's lovely to be
with you this evening thanks
to counselors for the invite so um it's
a shame we're not around a table
um having having this conversation maybe
next year
so um most of you will know what
citizen's advice is um here for
and what we're designed to do but but
i'll just um
briefly run through that if i can on
slide
um two please so and we are here um as
an independent charity to help people
move forward with the issues that
they're facing in society
and we are um a local independent
charity
and we run across storage north mid and
west evan as council of penton has
alluded to it's quite a mouthful but
the data and information that i'm going
to talk to you about
this evening it's purely around torridge
district
council area as you would um as you
would um
expect so and we are uh independent
we're confidential
we're impartial in the advice and
information that we give
and we are regulated by the financial
conduct authority and accredited by the
advice
um advice um
sorry i've got my i've got my all of
these acronyms i usually just say aqs
but
the advice quality standards i didn't
want to use an accurate review
so we are accredited by the advice
quality standards agency
so we have physical locations within
torres district council so the bridgeton
street office
the training and business centre in
holsworthy and also castle hill
center in torrington um although
quite clearly through the covered
pandemic the offices the
physical public facing side of our
offices has
has unfortunately had to be closed
um we deliver advice and information via
a multi-channel
um service which is just as well given
um given what's happened with the
pandemic so
as well as the traditional face-to-face
we also support people through telephone
and through web chat and also through
the through the use of our
local website if we when we're trying to
empower people
to help themselves um and also more
recently
through email as well
um and i just wanted to sort of touch on
the pandemic impact really for
our staff and volunteers and also the
client demands as well
so in terms of our staff of which we
have
um 32 they are um they were all
still working all the way through
through the pandemic we were able to
within a two-week period um
make get everybody working remotely and
the majority
from their homes and we were um
fortunate in that we'd already invested
in um teams and internet-based
solutions for a communication so we were
very agile anyway which is great so we
were
able to to do that relatively smoothly
so i think we probably had about a two
week
gap of service um and then we picked up
again from there
in terms of our volunteers quite a lot
of our volunteers are elderly
and some of them have had stepped down
during the
lockdown period and some of them came
back again during the more relaxed
um periods but we went from 24
um volunteers in the biddeford office to
um 16 active volunteers so we are a few
down even though
we're very um still in contact with the
other ones and hoping that they'll come
back and join us when
the face-to-face services presume and in
terms of our client demand it's been
really interesting because through
april and into may we actually had
less demand for our services and what
we've
concluded that to be is that the kind of
like the accident an emergency scenario
where people are
putting off coming to us because they
think they don't want to be a nuisance
and
that we'd be busy are dealing with other
things but we certainly from
may from the end of may really then
picked up and we've seen demand
rocket from there so the dashboard data
that you can now see in front of you is
the
data from the first six month period so
bearing in mind
what i've just said about the april of
may being
relatively quiet so 1017
clients helped with over 2
200 issues and just for our newer
counsellors tonight
we record clients and issues separately
because most of our clients
have more than one problem even if they
present with one particular issue there
tends to be
two and sometimes three other at least
two and sometimes
three issues that we end up giving
advice and information on
um 51 of our clients that we've helped
in this period
are um have a disability or a long-term
health condition
and our volunteers contributed um
28 000 hours in
sorry 2800 hours and that's darren
alluded to
um from from his um from his
speaker from his talking that we that
there's a fiscal value
in volunteering you know it's it's not
free as such but
if we were having to pay your volunteers
for the work that they've done in that
in that period we'd be paying them in
excess of 70 or thousand pounds so
it just goes to show doesn't it the
value of volunteering and i think we've
all recognized that
through the pandemic the value of local
volunteers
and in terms of income gain so income
gain for that period has been 330 000
pounds so
income gain is where we've supported
people to
maximize the income into the family
household and actually generally through
welfare benefit
uplift but it can be through other other
things as well such as grants
through various projects that we work
with
thank you the next slide
next slide please i'm excited five
minutes vicky
okay okay so top five categories so
um we have seen um just again in this
period
um lots of people coming to us for
support around
welfare benefits so not knowing what
they're entitled to or changing
circumstances
um welfare benefits universal credit is
another huge
area for us um due to the fact that a
lot of people
are um are being furloughed or they're
being made redundant during this period
so we've seen a huge increase in people
coming to us for
support around that and we've also seen
an increase in people coming to sorry
things
um for employment issues so again
people concerned about where they stand
with their employment um
particularly around redundancy and
furlough um also relationships and
family
has gone up as well worth people
struggling to be
at home with each other or um you know
the stresses and strains that those
debt and um welfare benefits and changes
in family situations can
can bring on okay so that's the sort of
top
issues and if any it's worth me saying
at this point if any counselor is
particularly interested in data around
their ward we can
provide that for you just need to drop
me an email we're more than happy to
have that conversation with you
so how do our clients reach us so we've
talked about the sort of traditional
verses this year so
this year or last year into this year
the majority of
support that we've provided has been
over the telephone
um some web chats some email we've also
more recently launched a messenger
service as well a lot of people like to
come through us through facebook
messenger as their
um initial contact and we still do um
we we still do help people with with
sort of letters and letters coming in
but that's
um it's been it's actually been um an
increase in this year for people writing
to us for help
but generally that isn't very um very
popular way of doing it
so thank you next slide please so in
terms of profile
um so split between
male and female so um 61 female and
um 39 males coming to us and we talked
about the
already the long-term health condition
and the disability
ratios that we're finding and that's
norm about normal actually it's usual
for us to be dealing with about 50
of our clients claiming to have or have
a registered disability or long-term
health condition
thank you next slide so in terms of um
the funding that we received from torres
district council that contributes to
what we call our generalist service so
the volunteer-led part of our service we
also have a number of paid
projects um where we are funded by
particular funders
and to deliver specific projects and the
added benefit
to anybody coming through the citizens
advice door
is that they then get access to these
other projects that
are specific to their needs so
i've just listed them for you here i
won't go through them
all but what i would like to just
mention is our macmillan
um project that we've been running for
for 10 plus
years now supporting cancer sufferers
and people with other life limited
conditions again this is about income
maximization
about entitlements and also
grants that are available to people that
are in this
unfortunate position the universal
health claim
is a project that we run across the
country it's dwp
funded and it's there to support
first-time claimants with
of universal credit and navigating their
way through that
complex system most importantly we
have two one and now another one which
is great
um debt projects so we have four
full-time debt case
workers working across the torridge and
broader area
and um thank goodness for that because
we are anticipating
a 60 increase in the clients coming to
us for
debt related issues on the back of the
impact of the kobe's
pandemic and as you can see lots of
other good projects there where we're
helping to support
um different cohorts of clients and this
is a
more case working more detailed work
with those with those people
thank you next slide so what do our
clients have to say to us so really
important for us to get um to always
understand
the feedback from our clients and to try
to better the service that they received
so
um 98 of our clients in the surveys that
have happened between this period
um say that they would recommend people
coming to
to torridge for advice to tourist
citizens advice
four and five um said that the advice
that we've given them
has had a positive impact on their lives
um
and seventy percent um so they feel less
stressed
depressed and anxious and we're learning
more and more about
the link between um low mental health
and
financial um financial health so
we're doing quite a lot of work with gp
surgeries um linked to the social
prescribing but the advice element of
that
and also 75 percent um now
feel that they um they know more about
their issue and they feel better
equipped to help themselves in the
future
and this is really important to us
because as an organization we really
struggle
to meet demand so um for us it's about
not just helping the client with the
problem that they have but trying to
educate them so they're better placed
to not get themselves in that same
situation or to understand how to deal
with it if they
if they do okay thank you next slide
okay so very important second part of
what we do as a charity
is research and campaign so this is
advocacy and policy work
so we have a link directly into
government um
around policy and one of the huge things
that we got involved with was the
universal credit and the changes that
have happened over the last couple of
years to that to that benefit and how
people go about claiming
so and we gather evidence from our
clients
about things that are going wrong um in
society and we're able to take that
straight up through our national team to
government to
um campaign for policy change and that
sometimes we do get
actively involved with our local mps as
well if the issue is particularly
affecting local communities
okay and i think that in 10 minutes is
all i can say so i'm more than happy to
take any questions you've done superbly
well i really appreciate i had no blue
hands they were watching
with intent vicky so thank you for your
presentation
um any blue hands there
uh if i missed any tom i don't see
anything you've got to
yeah uh first of all country cottle
honkin
cheryl oh thank you sorry um i was just
gonna ask about the gender breakdown
because it was 62 female which is up
from 55
previously i was just wondering about if
you could
shed a bit light on that imbalance yeah
no i'd like to say that i could you know
it changes actually um
no there's no real rationale behind it
there isn't anything
particular that we've seen any
differently it could i mean it could
just be due to you know who's at home
who's the mate who makes the contact
but there isn't um when we've looked at
issues in relating to
you know women with more more women
issues there isn't any
correlation to the to the figure so
it'll be interesting to see what it
looks like at the end of the year
hey come back sure are you happy with
the answer yeah that's fine thank you
personal leather please
thank you chair yeah first one's a
niggle
first one is a niggle i'm also a member
of northern town council as well as a
district yeah and i noticed on the
introduction page no mention of northern
but
you do mention biddeford town council
holds worthy
town council and torrington town
councils
we've always granted to the
citizens advice we've always spoken very
strongly
about for our support for it and i'd
like to mention that
if any are going to be mentioned
northern town counts are only slightly
smaller than benefit town council
anyway i'll leave it at that can i just
confirm so all we were saying was that
where we have offices
not not who's funding us it's where
we're located
right says here the funding to operate
our generalist services is helped with
grant from torres district council oh i
see
right sorry we also received regular
donations from biddeford town council
holsworthy town council and torrington
town council oh and we haven't mentioned
you i'm so sorry
okay we'll rectify that for the end of
the year thank you very
much the other thing is on the on the
debt on your
advice categories yes the five that
you've got there no debt
i remember two or three years ago debt
was a huge problem with the citizen
advice in biddeford
i think the average debt that people
were coming to the advice center was
with somebody like 30 000 pounds
it was a huge figure i thought at the
time then
i'm interested to see on the pie chart
there
it's it's relatively small it's
obviously a big problem for some people
and you did mention
and this is up to september of last year
so it covers the kovid year the first
covered year
is it reducing slightly are the levels
of debt reducing or are there just more
but smaller sums of money i'm keen to
think
how how it is changing yeah
bearing in mind all the grants that the
government have been pushing out for
this corvid
issue yeah i think it's an actual really
valid point so
um in terms of what so for us it's
twofold so one of
the reasons that our our figures are
down specifically for debt is that
from a resourcing perspective and two of
our
paid members of staff that were working
on our debt service were unfortunately
unable to work through
through the covid um or unable to work
at the levels that they had previously
worked through
through the co-vis so we've had some
resourcing issues there but also what we
found with debt
is that um because of all the support
that's been provided by
the government and through local um
hardship funds etc and through the
fellow scheme that
not not as many people are dealing with
their death issues or their debt issues
haven't been fully exposed yet
um our national team are have
anticipated a 60
increase in demand for debt services
over the coming 12 months so i think
actually
the the real answer to your question is
going to come
through the next 12-month period but we
see torridge as we all know is an area
of deprivation and there is a
huge amount of debt out there um
and i think that's only going to
increase in the coming months
thank you thank you vicky thank you
chris
uh councillor langford surely please
thanks
thank you thanks ever so much vicky um
just two quick ones if it's okay
um in the information that was sent to
us it said that um
for outcomes clients often don't return
so you can't always tell what the
outcomes are
i was just wondering is there is there
um is there a policy to follow up
or do you sort of um in the interest of
their privacy
deliberately not do that and the other
thing is in terms of the age groups of
people
uh coming to you have the age groups
changed at all this year because of
covert etc or has it remained pretty
much the same
thank you thank you so yes so certainly
in terms of the
follow-up so yes we do we would like to
follow up
and we try to follow up wherever
possible sometimes it's not possible
because the clients ask us not to or
they're not
they wouldn't necessarily pick up the
phone but also again it's a resource
issue for us in that we are
um we're quite demand heavy so
we don't necessarily have always the
resource to be able to follow up on
outcomes particularly if their benefit
uplift outcomes so and that might take a
while to you know
come to fruition but it is something
that we want to do because of course
it's about impact as well particularly
when we're talking to our funders we
want to be able to
show just how much impact we've had on
on the clients in the community and how
much money we're bringing back into the
community so
i think it's something we could do
better on um but it's just about having
a resource to do it
and then in terms of the profile yes we
have seen a change in profile so
um we're finding that a lot more working
age people are coming to us
um and i think just you know the the
issues that the pandemic has caused
um are more broader so the typical
things that we
deal with um you know it's outside of
that i guess so yes we are seeing and
there's a piece of analysis that's
happening actually and i think we'll
know
we'll be able to give you a better
picture as to why that is at the end of
the financial year
so we are certainly seeing a different
demographic of clients
and it's really on the back of concerns
around
the impact of kobe thank you
thank you sir coaster newton
um vicky thanks very much for your
presentation
um can i just ask you on uh one point
that you covered at the end and that is
your campaigning
is your campaigning to resolve
issues in systems that that currently
um exist or do you
campaign to change policy
and as such i i would hope especially
given
taking note of where uh quite a lot of
your funding comes from i would hope
that you are
apolitical in your approach can you
confirm that
or do you consider that you have a
political edge
in your campaigning yes so um thank you
for that question so we remain
um politically neutral and even when
we're in
agreement with let's say dwp to deliver
a project we're always
absolutely certain and written into the
contract that we will remain independent
in terms of the support that we provide
to clients
so um so we do remain independent
in terms of what we're campaigning for
so it can be it can be different
depending on
on what the issue is that we're finding
but we will campaign
yes to change policy at government level
so universal credit is
is um an area that we we have worked on
we can but we also want to look at very
local
um local policy as well or of things so
like council tax protocol for example
we would work with with your district
council offices on council tax protocol
if we felt that
or we were hearing from our clients that
there was
pressure on clients and such so it can
be either
actually no that's quite clear happy
with that but you're not coming from any
particular
political base no no good thank you
right i see no further hands i have
would have a
a couple of questions but i think okay
so i don't see a blue hand sorry is that
the pressure forward no
no cherry it's kind of 40 i don't know
why i can't get me blue and up or
whether it should be a yellow one red
one or a green one if we want to be
politically correct
plus there's a purple one at all yeah
but could i just have
a minute or two please yes please thank
you uh
thank you vicky i have known this lady
for many many years and i
think she's very neutral um and actually
i i did notice actually just now she
actually did praise
um to some degree the
funding from government to actually
underpin the problems we got
in initial part of a speech actually um
so i'll wait for the fact she's a
political
and yes i would totally agree
that things are being uh put down until
next year it's going to be a lot worse
probably than this year because we
you know whether we like it or not uh
councillor newton again
um i do try to be independent i'm quite
happy to
be critical of green yellow
blue or red um quite an equal measure
but when we've actually got food banks
perhaps we need them
we've actually lost shore star perhaps
we needed that thank god we got
furloughed
um minimum wage when it should be a
living wage there's many things we can
moan about
but um thank god i think we all agree
that in general uh we do need a citizen
advice bureau
i've even used it myself actually only
about three years ago when i lost my job
after eight years
so let's keep this non-political and i
mean that
um where we can help um let's all do
that
and it's sad that we actually need it
like we need food banks and everything
else thank you chad
thank you coachella ford have i missed
any other hands
please shout if i'm missing hands i
don't see any other blue hands here for
that one
i got a couple of uh one question
universal credit for myself because um i
got out of
i've already declared my personal
interest because i worked for cab
i couldn't face universal credit any
longer i hit 60 and
i've been through several changes to the
benefit system
universal credit it's a thing of the
last resort now for for some of our
our clients do you have an
immediate access to the dwp
or whoever is now the sponsoring
authority because people are struggling
to get
through how does it work vicky with your
work with the dwp and universal credit
can you tell me
yeah absolutely thank you so the
contract that we have with dwp is to
support first-time
claimants only um so
that's that's what we're doing so
there's a telephone number that i'm
happy to share i don't have it with me
now but i can drop it out as an email
so that would be for people claiming
first-time payments we can support them
and help to navigate them them to
navigate the system
because we know that it's complex and
difficult for people to navigate
um yes we've also fed back actually
and our clients are telling us that they
can't get through to the dwp
general helpline around universal credit
we don't have an in there as such you
know we can't sort of bypass any
is the telephone number that the public
have is the one that that we have but i
have spoken to
the north devon um mp about it
um because we have had concerns around
people
being on hold 45 minutes to an hour in
fact we have been on hold
for 45 minutes to an hour while trying
to support clients through that system
have you been you've been to the north
devon mp and not the tourism west devon
mp
we've been to uh so so far the policy so
as
when we talk about policy and evidence
so so far it's been some of our north
devon
um clients that have we've been working
with that we've
evidenced that so we've spoken to celine
saxby about
it and she was going to um to go back up
to parliament because i believe she sits
on
that parliamentary group excellent
yes we've spoken to celine about it very
good contact thank you for
that any further blue hands to questions
to vicky pacifically on
citizen advice for torridge no
so thank you very much indeed vicky for
the moments
and um come forth because some questions
will come up later on i think
after i'm going to ask claire um
fisher from encompass now to lead us for
the next agenda item um
and speak about her role and in the same
vein as the previous two speakers so
claire thank you very much for giving up
your
evening this evening and uh looking
forward to your presentation and what
you have to say before us
claire fisher please thank you chair um
yeah good evening um
as uh council pennsylvania my name is
claire fisher
and i'm the chief executive of a charity
called encompass southwest
um i feel a little bit like chris
whittie tonight and i will probably be
saying next slide
quite regularly so um so yeah next slide
please
um so i just want to talk to you a
little bit about encompass southwest who
we are some of you may well have known
us previously as
poverty action group um bpag we
um we've been around for the last 26
yeah just over 26 years um and
we were amalgamated in 2012 to becoming
camp
encompass southwest which really you
know the name itself encompasses the
work that we
do across um both north devon torridge
and through our partnerships takes us
into west devon and mid devon
um we are a completely independent
charity registered charity
and we provide a range of advice
information and support services
um to the people within our community
and we've got a strong focus on um
working in both
rural and rural remote settlements um
just to give you an update on our it's
an indication of our size we employ 22
paid members of staff and we currently
have 11 volunteers working for us
um our work is um divided into three key
areas um they are our housing um and
homelessness and rough sleeping services
and we work both with
adults and young people and the youngest
we go down to is 14.
um you may well have seen on our social
media or when you've been out and about
we
have a youth outreach team that work
along um
uh biddeford and i think tonight they're
actually um in westwood ho
so yeah so we work with young people
that are
potentially at risk of um
of going missing from home or or just
struggling at home
and just need that additional support
and we also offer a variety of supported
accommodation and i will talk to you a
little bit further about that as we go
along
um and we also do some financial
inclusion work so it's been it's been
wonderful to hear um
the work of both ttvs and cab
and and and i'd love you know we want to
strengthen how we can kind of all work
together a little bit more in terms of
some of the money and debt advice that
that we deliver
um so we um as part of our money debt
advice it does sit slightly outside but
we are a key partner in the wiser money
partnership which is a joint
um jointly delivered with navigate cic
um which some of you may well have seen
over the last couple of years
uh next slide please um so
to give you an insight into our our
homeless system of sleeping services we
um i've been in the role uh since 2011
but most recently in the role of chief
officer since 2018
and one of the first things that i
implemented in my role was ensuring that
as an organization
we're working with some of the most
complex multi-disadvantaged people
within our community
and it's really important that we start
to work in what is called
what we talk about is a trauma informed
and psychologically informed framework
so from the outset of me coming in as
chief officer i was really keen to
ensure that we
we made sure that our policies our
procedures and all of our
team were supported to work in that way
and when i talk about children informed
i talk about
the recognizing that many of the people
that we support have come from severe
trauma and
and often they have ex have had real
adverse childhood experiences
and so we it's very simple it's simple
as things
that's asking instead of asking what's
wrong with you um which we often do
as professionals say what's wrong it's
it's switching that and saying what's
happened to you and not
re-traumatizing people and supporting
them to be able to make positive changes
in their lives
a pace that they um they're ready to
make that change rather than us as
professionals
so a lot of our work is yes absolutely
charity we're always looking at funding
but a lot of our work at the moment is
very much focused around system change
and and you know there's a saying uh
albert einstein said
um the definition of insanity is doing
the same thing and expecting different
results
uh and i think you know we've kind of
hit a pivotal point in in our
development at the moment is about
actually we have to start to change that
system and how we work with people
differently
um so some of the projects that we
deliver around our housing and
homelessness services that
focus around a trauma informed um
psychologically informed framework is we
deliver housing first
um this is a some of you may well have
seen this has been on news over the last
12 months um it originally came from
america and
um finland and it's about working with
some of the most complex enough sleepers
that we've got to give them both a
property
and support for as long as they need it
and often that can be for life
um it's about giving those people choice
um and it's also
working on a strength-based way so
rather than focusing on what hasn't
worked for them it's about focusing on
what has worked well
and building on that uh that framework
to date we've got 11 people working
11 people house who are housing first
which doesn't sound a lot
but actually when i tell you these are
people that um you know
agencies and um professionals have
deemed in the past
unhousable and suit and supportable um
and a recent example actually is one
client our first client that we put into
housing first
who um who was um
you know a real drain it would be fair
to use that word on public services
especially the police um i had a
conversation with them around six months
ago and they actually thought he'd
passed away
um and we said no no he's living quite
happily uh in newport and and he's doing
really really well so just to give you
that indication of you know those
the people that we work with are those
very high complex needs
um we have a variety of supported
accommodation
um across north devlin and uh torridge
uh very much again focused around uh the
trauma informed but we also
offer um accommodation to people that
are
um in couples and also we have
gender female only accommodation um
we deliver on behalf of torres district
council we deliver the
torridge outreach service um and also
the
um streetwise project which again our
work streetwear is working with young
people and we deliver the statutory
obligat the strategy duty on behalf of
the local authority
and that works really well and it has
done for i believe it's around eight
years we're coming up to now on that one
um we've also got funding from people
like junction and need to deliver a site
from children in need to deliver our
junction project
and most recently um in the last 12
months we've set up a new partnership
with
mind mental health and north devon
against domestic abuse called the women
first project
it's it's it's been an amazing project
when we first set out we said we'd work
with 60 people
over a period of 18 months uh we're 12
months into the project and we've worked
with 97 women
these are women that um aren't
necessarily
really visual on the on the streets as
being rough sleeping but
um but actually what it's raised is
there's some real inequalities around
female homelessness but also that
actually female homelessness
it presents itself in a completely
different way to how males
um male homelessness does we've also
set up just before christmas and
emergency winter accommodation we were
successful
in some funding to uh the homelessness
transition
fund through homeless link and we now
have
11 at the moment we've got 11 placements
up in
in ilferkum holiday park and so we've
been able to
put people in and i guess really one of
our greatest achievements
um since covert is actually just before
christmas other than one gentleman whose
choice was to stay out
in torridge we've actually managed to
house everybody um so we had everybody
in
um before christmas um next life please
uh um so yeah talk a little bit about
housing first there just i've listed
there the key principles i think they're
really really important and they do
guide us in terms of
how we work with people into around
housing and those principles are
we absolutely believe that everybody has
the right to a home
nobody is unhouseable nobody is
unsupportable we just as agencies we're
not meeting their needs
um we provide flexible support to all of
the people we work with and that's
as long as they need it we you know as
an organization we do some great work
we are not capable of untangling uh you
know 20 years of of trauma
in nine months so it's important that we
and other agencies recognize that and we
start to work with those clients for as
long as they need them
um and actually on the housing first
half housing and support is separated
so so one isn't isn't um restricted to
the other
so if you have a property or you don't
have a property we still provide the
support
and and we support you to find that
property so just if you lose your house
doesn't mean then you lose your support
um individuals have choice and control
and it's really important that we start
now to give those individuals that and
give them a voice
and so we've been developing a lot of
work through the making every adult
matter
frame um partnership to ensure that we
are
we are delivering what i consider a high
fidelity co-production model
um the service is based on people's
strengths goals and aspirations it's a
human-based model
um and it's about an active engagement
approach so actually with housing first
people don't have to engage
they can have the house shut the door
and tell us to go away and that's fine
however we might go away on monday but
we're back again on tuesday
and we're back again on thursday um and
eventually they do start to engage with
us but
but they don't get penalized for that
and it's a harm reduction approaches
used so we don't
insist that people stop drinking or they
stop taking drugs we support those
people to do that in a harm reduction
way so it's done safely
and actually interestingly on our
housing first all of our clients where
we haven't put those restrictions on
them they've all addressed
their issues and one lady um who
who was very visual in torridge and in
north devon
um a big drinker she's now been cleaned
she's living in one of our housing first
properties and
a month just before christmas purchased
her first car when she's driving now so
again you know we but we weren't
insistent that she stopped drinking that
was her choice
um uh next slide just thinking of time
clear
a couple of minutes yeah that's great
i'm nearly there i think
so come in our first project is
um as i said partnership between the
data and mind
um we've said when i was writing this
report supported over 90 women
um we do have a bit of a plug here but
we do have a gender informed conference
on the 27th of january it's completely
free to attend
ten till two we have some amazing guest
speakers and it's an opportunity to
to just um come together as um
as a group of people that really want to
to
um raise and see how we can
um you know reduce some of those
inequalities around female homelessness
so again i will put the
send the link out to everybody but it
would be great if anybody wanted to join
us on that
uh next slide
um again talk about just to give you an
example there the kind of accommodation
that we have in the area
so we've got an eight bed mixed
accommodation in barnstable an eight bed
mixed accommodation in biddeford
we've got a three bed mixed
accommodation in barnstable
um a four bed female accommodation in
barnstable
and we have just signed the lease on a
four bed accommodation in biddeford
which will be female only and that's
actually going to be our first
accommodation that we're delivering in
partnership with mind and the dada so
um that that's you know really really
interesting model and and it's going to
be some a legacy off of the women's
first project
and again we have the one bedroom winter
units that we've been able to offer so
our accommodation offers offer is
building
uh we are continuing to strengthen that
and develop that based on what the need
is locally
uh financial inclusion services so again
very much just a quick introduction into
that but as i said it is wise
it's through our wiser money partnership
we are regulated by the fca
and i guess where we sit slightly
differently we tend to work with really
complex clients
often don't even recognize they're in
crisis so referrals will tend to come
from um social workers um
uh housing officers if for example you
know somebody's got the bailiffs
knocking on the door
um and so we're funded by a variety of
different
um trusts there
money advice budgeting and benefits i
have a question do you happen to take a
question
now as it might be topical to what
you're saying from councillor mckenzie
yeah absolutely yeah sure councilor
mackenzie please you've got your blue
hand up there yeah i was just gonna ask
um if you supported
families um i know of a local family
that's just been through uh
a particularly traumatic um incident of
domestic abuse which
now requires um accommodation for
three children and and themselves um
is is all your accommodation all around
sort of like um
you know single people and couples or
can you accommodate yeah
so predominantly um yeah predominantly
it is around single people and around
couples
um what i would say though we are able
to offer advocacy in terms of
um access and support through the local
authority so um
to be able to give them advice in terms
of um yeah what what support might be
available to them and also
yeah that advocacy in terms of if we
feel maybe they're not getting the
support that they
should be getting so um yeah definitely
we can give support on that
unfortunately our housing though we
don't take families at the moment just
because of the
the hm you know our hmos are mixed and
we have people
with varying issues in there and we
certainly wouldn't be wanting to bring
children into that environment
okay thanks i'll be in touch around that
family then thanks yeah definitely
unclear i'll give you another two
minutes because of the question so
fire away oh so okay
so um yeah so so um we also have in
ilforcum just 39 notes
not twice but we have got a new advice
center there which we're going to be
opening unfortunately kovid's
um delayed that somewhat and so we are
hoping that maybe in the spring if
things start to relax then we'll start
to open that but
that is a again we're looking at a
one-stop shop where it can be
information around financial inclusion
services
um around young people around housing
homelessness
so fingers crossed yeah as things start
to to relax we'll start to open that one
up
um very soon so next slide i think i'm
nearly there to be honest i feel
wonderfully
yeah youth projects uh just to give you
a bit so like i said we've got the
street outreach
we are again kobit has kind of delayed
this a little bit but we are
hoping very soon to relaunch our host
family scheme and i think you know we
will see as things change when we start
to come out of the pandemic
we are anticipating that there will be a
far higher number of young people and
adults that are requiring housing as
everybody's aware that kept the
government put a stop on that eviction
although i think it has just changed
recently
in terms of um if there's six months or
more debt then
then they can apply to be evicted but um
so we're anticipating seeing far more
people needing our services and so in
terms of young people
we are looking at setting up a new host
family scheme
um we like say we're providing youth
homes to support
through um our children in need project
and
also we have got a project that works
with care leavers so we can provide
support to care leavers
that are just starting to come out of
that out of the system to be able to
support and navigate their way through
to independence next slide please
and yeah oh there you go perfect
questions i put our details on there
there's a
few um uh our website email
etc and our facebook and twitter so but
yeah if anybody's got any questions i'd
be happy to answer them
really thank you very much indeed for
your presentation counselor langford has
got the blue hand up
shirley please hi claire thanks ever so
much for that
um just a couple of quick ones in terms
of the the care of this project
it was mentioned earlier in the
presentation called the ripple project
is that specifically in relation to
housing or does it cover
support for care leaders in lots of ways
and my other question was
am i right in thinking that
predominantly what you do is more to do
with
outreach and referrals to you as opposed
to people coming direct to you
or is it a mix of both thank you
yep so um in response to your first
question with the care leavers
we um it is there is definitely a
housing
link to it but we are able to work with
people that maybe
are housed but need that additional
support
um so it yeah so i think you know people
people can refer
into that project it is um
it's due to come to an end at the end of
october we are still taking referrals at
the moment
and um and yeah and we can certainly
look but there is certainly
there is a twist you know there's
certainly a link or stream running
through it in terms of
trying to make sure that people don't
hit don't hit the streets or if they are
trying to access accommodation
for them um in terms of your second
question
um people can self-refer absolutely um
we have um our website where we have a
online chat on there i have to say
that it's not always manned
late at night um and often we will
respond first thing in the morning
um but people can can post messages on
there
we have our social media where we have
messages on there and we do
outreach so um my team go out at the
moment i think it's every
um every week either on thursday morning
they settle for about half past four or
five o'clock in the morning and they
go across torridge um to the known areas
and especially if we've got intelligence
of where people are
then again we could we we do that so we
we are out early in the morning
to um try and engage with people that
might be uh
sleeping um but yes that was
thank you thanks very much thank you uh
councillor clark who's our lead member
on turrets for
homelessness and housing yeah hi claire
um could you please um send me the link
for the 27th of january so i can be in
that meeting
yes absolutely that would be good um
yeah that's what i'll do um yeah i'll
email it directly i'm just i don't
know if i can i'm not great resume i
have to be honest i'm more of a teams
girl
but um i will see if i can put it in the
chat possibly if not i will email it to
you
if you could email it to me that'd be
great because then we can uh get
together because i've got a whole list
of things that
that we're dealing with with you so i'll
bring them up in my presentation later
on
and can i just say if councillor
mckenzie's listening
can you give me a shout out your
predicament
and um i may be able to help there as
well
thank you very much mark yeah
okay so councillor clark and councillor
mckenzie will talk to each other
uh coaster o'connell honkin
hello i was just gonna ask about
finances because the other two were
talking about funding at the end of
their presentations
um and it appears that your finances are
getting stronger
um do you require any extra or should i
not really answer that question
i would always say we always need
actually no so
um it's actually really interesting
actually because you mentioned
sorry north devon council has dear
receive funding from them what's the do
you support
north devon more than torridge or what
how does that
break yeah so um so in terms of
our funding model we um again when it
came in one of the things we were
looking at we're
very very heavy reliant on um grants and
foundations
and we reckon that we didn't have a
crystal ball and see covered
but we did we did realize that actually
things are
were going to start to change so we had
to start to have a look
at our um you know our strategic
direction
and our our funding and to have a look
at
how we can become more sustainable and
one of the key parts for that was about
bringing on accommodation you know we
recognized in the area
there was accommodation happening but it
really wasn't um
you know there was improvements that
could have been made so part of our
journey took us down that route of
accommodation and have to say you know
that has been
um that has been great in being able to
fund the placements the support and also
it of the
element that funds our management costs
um
in terms of the projects so we
um we have so the women's first is a
prime example actually
we've had funding through homeless link
through the tampax tax fund to be able
to deliver that women's first project
and and
that has given us over the last 12
months some really amazing statistics
and
both qualitative and quantitative data
so and we're now in discussions with
both
local authorities about how we then
start to embed that within their
outreach strategies
so i think we've really had to strip
back in terms of our core projects so
understanding
who we are what we are what we do and
not trying to stretch ourselves too thin
which we were absolutely guilty of you
know we were
pushing running for to funding and
trying to make that funding
fit or our projects fit that funding and
so so when we actually came back and we
we
kind of um looked at what is our core
projects what is it we want to do
and that's where we're focusing i think
covert has allowed us to apply for a lot
of
um emergency funding which is great and
that's been that has really helped us
this year
it's been huge but the reality i guess
is that you know that is going to go um
and um our funding yeah so
so it's we've had to work a lot we've
had to work really hard on it
um i think it is the question and really
focus on on what is
what is priority what do we need to fund
and how do we make that sustainable
um in terms of the work across toyota
north devon if you'd have asked me this
question sort of two years ago i would
have said majority of our work is in
north devon um that we've seen a real
shift in that
and actually a lot of our work now is in
towards in terms of our rough sleeper
work
um so we have been doing we have really
joined up with helen page and her team
at housing options
we've got a you know there's a really
good professional relationship there in
terms of transparency what we're doing
what they're
doing and how we can kind of come
together on that um
and so so yes i think you know a lot of
the work now is focused on twitch and i
have to say
i i honestly believe in terms of the
rough sleeper work that and the
that we're doing in torch we're leading
the way um
we are really looking at innovative ways
of working
um and that is supported by by the meme
approach we've also got some support
from devon county council
um and the one northern devon we're
heavily involved in one northern devon
um and and we are yeah torch is leading
the way on it
it might you know in my opinion um and i
i see
from all over all different areas but
they're actually
they're allowing themselves the
flexibility to think differently
and i guess having the trust in us as an
organization as well that
we're not going to do something that
could put anybody at risk
where our decisions are made on what we
know
and what we know needs to change so yeah
thank you really good thank you good
answer are you happy with
any other questions for claire
from encompass claire can i just ask you
a question
um i live on the outskirts of biddy food
um and um we have various bits of
woodland around us
um occasionally we come across tents in
these woodlands
um an occasional giveaway usually summer
times is small
it was up in the valleys from fires
that lit by the residents um is there a
perception i've got
but is there a perception that people
choose
rough sleeping in the in the summer
months because of the poor quality of
housing
that they're facing across the districts
have i got a a
perception problem myself or is that
actually happening
no i i've only ever come across
probably a handful of people that have
chosen to must sleep
um and that is that you know that
and their reasons are really valid often
because
it's safer being outside than it is to
be in a home um
if you're uh young if you know if you're
somebody that has had
adverse childhood experiences and i know
you know on the gender informed
conference we've got a lady that talks
on that about lived experience and when
i first met her she talked about
um you know as a child you talk about
the bear in the woods the bear was
her dad that lived at home so she used
to go home every day to the bear
and actually as things when she could
leave she left and and actually it was
it was safer to be in the woods and it
was to be in the house because
um the bear wasn't in the woods uh and
so people make that choice
so they say actually no it's i feel
safer outside because nobody could you
know
i can't be abused i can't be whatever is
happening um to me
i feel safer here so that's a choice and
we have to work with people really
closely
um to build that relationship and that
trust up with them
um only like say only a handful of those
have chosen no that's what i want to be
i want to be outside
the majority of people want to be in
it's not that there's
the right it yes there's not the right
housing
but it's that actually we've never given
those people the choice
um we've always said this is as a
professional where you should be living
because this is what we've got and what
we're actually doing now is turning it
that on our head and saying actually no
that's not acceptable anymore people
should have choice if you're somebody
that has come from you know
a a chartered trauma you know those out
the ten aces a lot of the people that we
work with have a minimum
of eight of those aces and um
you know and they've never had choice
ever
and and so we're just we're just
following that route of well you're not
worthy of that choice so
when you start to give that to people
then yes they do choose where they want
to live um then actually and and often
they want their own front door
the same as all of us i'm sure you know
we wouldn't want to i wouldn't want to
be living in an eight bed
accommodation where it is lots of
complex needs people so
you know our accommodation we have to be
really careful about who we bring in
to make sure that balance is right so
you know and that that's where we're
changing that model and working with
torich at the moment to look at one bed
flats
because that's what people want they
want their own front door
thank you any further questions just
specifically for encompass
hello uh chair counselor for you forward
sorry yes i can't see a blue hand
i know i know i don't know what i'm
doing here to you know perhaps i just
object to using the blue and i don't
think so really
and carry on pressure forward yeah i'll
keep this very brief because great
presentation
uh to be fair and i didn't know you know
i'm always very honest than that didn't
know
a lot about this organization i did a
great job
um and i just want to just just be a bit
just to prove i've actually read the
document clear actually but if you look
at the no this is quite funny just me
being a bit of a
pedantic maybe pra actually i shouldn't
use that language perhaps but anyway
look at the slide where you've got thank
you we couldn't have achieved this
without you
if you listen on the left-hand side page
16
um you get down to and it's got
nationwide bank
basketball branch yes yeah well they
don't exist it's a building society
my bad yes but it proves i've read it
right i'm just being
well done i was hoping somebody would
spot that actually council afford so
well done on that one yeah
no but thanks very good honestly i
didn't know about what you've done great
report i appreciate it thank you
no thank you thank you for that
right as i see no further blue hands can
i make sure that we thank all three
presenters for these uh agenda items and
the way they presented them and the way
they've taken the questions on their
pacific organizations
um uh i want to come now and
i don't think we need to suspend
starting orders or anything but
i just wonder if we could have a round
table discussion
if that is at all possible about the
issues that colwood is throwing up and
how these organizations that we have
listened
so clearly from and the great jobs they
appear to be doing
um that they are doing um the the the
uh some of the cross-cutting issues that
they may be able to throw some light and
work on
and i i have got a couple of i don't
know if anybody else has got a
cross-cutting issue that they would like
to ask the way to go forward counselor
leather i see a hand going up here
thanks chair well it's not to do with
kobe specifically
it's from reading the three and thank
you to all three
who presented to us tonight and i i know
we all appreciate the work they do
in the district for us um but one thing
that did occur to me
and reading through these documents
there is an overlap of services in quite
a few areas
and i would have thought that some joint
stroke cooperative working
is needed here between the three
organizations in some aspects
uh that would elicit a bigger bang for
your bucks i think if you did that
but i realize they're each doing their
own thing in specific areas
but certainly reading through these
three presentations
there are things where they're all doing
the same thing in in certain instances
thanks chair thank you can i
i think sorry yes i can
try and answer that a little bit i think
that um we
you know as the three organizations we
do talk and we i think we you know we
are
we are very clear about what each
individual organization does with that
be fair to and i know we've made
referrals to to citizen advice with
vicky we've made referrals through to
darren
and ttvs and likewise they've made
referrals to our service and i think
whilst there may well be you know very
small bits of overlap i think it's about
the
recognizing the client groups that we
work with um
and that each service is specific to
that client group
um so would that be fair vicki and
darren i think you know there are little
bits of overlap but i wouldn't say that
there is
a huge amount um in the area yeah i i
would
concern with that i think just some
reassurance to the counselors that i
i've actually sat on
meetings spiritual meetings this week
with both claire and darren all be at
separate meetings
so there is very much the understanding
of collaboration and partnership working
going forward and i think that the main
point you make is around cohorts of
clients and
and you know your ability to to work
very much more holistically with a
smaller number of clients and
uh whereas we're dealing with the the
massive the massive demand
of our clients so i think um there's
always ways of working closer i think we
recognize more than ever the need
for efficiencies and i i think we are
we're working towards that
well done thank you um just to echo that
one because um
i went uh darren i met darren for the
first time um
at a rugby club meeting when they
organized there and invited several
different organizations
to present what they were doing across
the area so i know ttvs was doing a
tremendous job
that wasn't the rugby club so um yes i i
i get an impression they're working very
much across the way there i accept that
there's the harding i think you've got a
blue hand here yes thank you chair
i'll just um thank all three um um
um uh people that the the
talk they gave us so informative and
basically
um we are facing a very dark time
i think especially with february coming
and with uh
with the mental health and um and people
being locked in together
uh that um you know how do you feel that
you are
ready for the onslaught of the of the of
the
times to come because uh you you all all
seem to be working together but you know
i i do you feel that you are ready for
it
do i should i take that one yeah so i
think um
as claire alluded to we would all you
would hope that we all have our
funding strategies and business plans
and yes we we didn't know covert was
coming but
there are other things and you know
other concern financial concerns that we
would all
need to be considering anyway so i think
it would be remiss of us
as growing organizations to just sit
back and not consider
um you know future funding and the
demand on services
i i mean we as a citizens advice um
charity are concerned about demand we
don't meet
current demand levels and we know
there's going to be um
an impact you know a greater demand from
the impact of kobe so
it is a concern and it feels for us that
we're always
just a little bit more stretched than we
want to be so even if we generate income
and we're providing more projects and
more
you know more income into the charities
support me more people the demand seems
to always
exceed our ability to to to cope with
this
so i think it is a concern and and as
we've alluded to perhaps not so much for
the next financial year because one
would hope that we're all robust enough
charities to have been able to carry
carry it through that you know through a
next year but certainly into years two
three and four postcode bid
and there is a real concern about where
funding comes from
thank you i don't know if the others
won't want to add anything to that
i think yeah i know just to wear what
you said vicky i think you know we we
are expecting a real um
influx of of referrals certainly around
the housing
and we you know we're trying to prepare
for that but
um you know it's very difficult to you
know we don't have a
very big stock of houses but we are
talking to the right people at the
moment and trying to
make sure that we are we are ready for
that but yeah i don't think you know i
don't think anybody knows the the
full impact and i think you know we'll
be seeing it for the next sort of three
four five years um you know
it's for the long haul thank you yes
yeah
and just just some for from my point of
view sorry i it's already been
articulated really well by both claire
and vicky but i mean we're seeing both
demand increase
and and also change as well so one of
the challenges for us particularly with
the cohort that we work with is is the
face to face activity
you can't do a lot of what we do online
um and we just had news today that
um um there's now uh jabs being made
available
um for frontline staff within the the
volunteer and
community sector so we i've just got
that before
i came into this meeting so we'll be
looking at sort of coordinating that
but again you know as i said it is the
mental health financially
covid kind of bizarrely threw um a lot
of small pops of money at us which kind
of helped us weather the storm
um but my worry and i've kind of alluded
to in our annual report as well is that
kind of long-term
strategic funding sort of taking us to
sort of year two year three
uh from this and i think that would be
um
that will pose a very real concern for
us at this point in time
thank you darren i've got a whole list
of councillors now putting their hands
up
um christopher claire hodgin our regular
attendant of this meeting with not on
the committee claire
please thank you very much mr chairman
i just wanted to go back to the issue
raised about overlap of provision of
services by the
three agencies and i would like to
emphasize the fact
that once you have started working and
engaging
with some of the most vulnerable in our
communities
that trust that you engender doesn't
uh readily respond to being referred to
another agency to deal with a specific
aspect of your your issues so it is
really important and i was really
um it was great to hear that all three
of these agencies are talking to one
another
and sharing expertise and information
and i think
as long as we've got the confidence that
that
relationship is existing an overlap
doesn't matter
that the client is king in this and that
they're getting the
right information and support
from someone that they're building a
relationship with
now i speak from experience because i
spent many years working
with some very challenging client groups
in my working life so i do fully
understand this and i commend them for
how they're engaging and how successful
they are being and i really do wish them
well but
carry on talking to one another and
using each other's expertise please
thank you hackett
yes thank you very much chair um while
our speakers are here tonight
i would just reiterate a point made by
the leader of devon county council john
hart
when he said that torridge district
council
will be in the top 10 councils
nationally affected by corona virus
because our reliance on hospitality
and care industries and he speculated
that maybe by the end of the summer we
might
have permanently lost 70 percent
of our hospitality outlets now
having been lead member for almost six
years now for health and well-being
i've become acutely aware that what we
have in torridge
is in some regards replicated with
agencies
in north devon district council only 8
10 12 miles away down the road in
barnstable
and i think with what is coming at us
in the next 12 18 24 months
there has to be a way of working smarter
to stop
the overlap we're going to have because
i think you're going to be inundated
because not only you've got coronavirus
but you've got the
the matter of the coastal communities
with the effect
of brexit on fishing
it could be a deluge that we're fighting
and we really need to monitor where
we're going because in north
in torridge and northern devon we have a
very high
suicide rate it's totally regrettable
it's not always preventable but we have
to be alive to it
and we have to do everything we can
to to try and address whatever markers
come our way
and work smarter in the future and
that's all i i've got to say
but there is this warning coming down
the track that we cannot and must not
ignore
thank you can i just
sorry just to add to comment on that i
think um i don't know
how involved that you've been with one
northern devon
you have much involvement with i have
some involvement with them
and i've got to say that one northern
devon
is not led by the councils
and that is a concern of mine it needs
to have political leads
rather than unelected members of the
community
who might not be getting the whole
picture and i think there's an
important distinction with the work we
do as councillors
and what northern devon are trying
themselves to do
yeah i mean we're obviously um we're
heavily involved in in the one northern
devon model specifically around the high
flow and i think it
um what you're talking about and what
councillor
um hodson talked about there there is
definitely some similarities in terms of
the
models that we're developing around the
team around the person so
again making sure that you know our
clients have that full
spectrum of services around them so
we're not having to tell their story 50
times and re-traumatize
but i think that there is also a lot of
work going on and i think it probably
would be worthwhile
um maybe seeing whether there is some
you know whether having somebody to come
and talk at that meeting and i know
janet's involved
in the one northern devon so um
apologies if i'm
you know already saying what you don't
know but but i think that has developed
somewhat now and there is very much
around we are starting to prepare for
exactly what you've said there
in terms of we're doing some work around
you know young people
youth flow we're doing some work around
the high intensity uses so people
mental health and um suicide so i think
that there is definitely some work
happening and it's probably worth
um maybe just having a an update and an
overview on that because i think you
know that there's a lot of work going on
some really really fantastic work to
prepare us for whatever's coming down
the track
thank you um does janet just want to say
sorry uh
uh independent member phil topham's got
his hand up um but i just wonder if john
williams our environmental officers
wanted to say anything on the one north
devon question
um only to confirm that we are working
very closely with with one northern
devon
on a range of projects in a range of
areas at the moment
and that includes um reviewing
and assisting in future governance
arrangements as well so
it's very much works in progress at the
moment but yes they are they are hugely
active and we're working very closely
with them on a
on a range of um of projects it might be
something to bring back to a future um
of the scrutiny meeting chair but uh at
the moment still a lot of work
in progress thank you very much uh then
we go to
our independent member phil topham
phil hello uh thank you very much and
thank you to the presenters
um given the you know the concerns about
what's going to happen over the next
year or so and the concerns about
funding um just thinking that
organizations that hold and support
their clients
also themselves management and their
their volunteers also need to fail held
and support
so this is an odd sort of way of asking
a question but if you
if for you three presenters and your
organizations
if you consider yourself in a family
relationship with central government
where are you in the family are you
parents and children siblings
in-laws cousins or complete outsiders
oh dear i'm not sure i finally get the
question
yeah no i think i think i've got the
first part of your question in terms of
the staff that we're supporting and i
think that is an absolutely valid point
um in terms of where we sit with the
government i'm not really sure to be
honest i think we're probably
fifth cousin removed but um but
but the staff stuff i can't speak on
behalf of the others but certainly
you know when covid came in it had a
massive impact on my team in terms of
their mental health
you know my team are out with the most
complex guys their work is about
face-to-face work and suddenly
i'm saying whoa hold fire you know put
the brakes on and we're going to do some
stuff over
zoom uh and it had a massive impact so
so
we one of the things we introduced from
covid and i would absolutely advocate
for this
to others is is i gave almost every
member of staff got two duvet days
on top of their uh their annual leave
and these are days where you know you
just you there's nothing in the diary
but
you wake up or and you just think i
can't do it today you know i've been sat
in these four walls for the last
three weeks on zoom and so staff can
just without any any explanation you
know they have to be sick it's not leave
but it's just a day where they go i need
a me day i need to think about me today
um because we were you know we're
holding so much for our clients because
it's so complex
and that's been taken on really really
well the other thing we do with all of
our team because they do work with
complex clients is that
um do it they used to have a group
session but since covid we've made it
one-to-one so every month they have
one-to-one with a psychotherapist
and they don't just talk about what's
happening in work it can be what's
happening in
in their lives in general and the staff
really appreciate that because it's
somewhere safe to offload
and it stops that burnout and people
feeling like you know
i don't know how much more i can take of
this and and the the
compassion fatigue as well you know
we're working with really complex
clients
and and we hear some really awful stuff
um
and and sometimes you can just get that
burn out from it and that compassion
fatigue and
do you know what i've got problems today
i don't want to hear yours so
so they really help um and the last one
that we've just introduced and we're
bringing in next week is
um is every wednesday between 4 30 and
5. i've now got a local pt
and we're we're making it's not
compulsory but the guys can just um
in work time that last middle of the
week the last half an hour work
uh that they can get up and do some some
exercises and stretches and stuff just
to help them
and i think that's really you know your
point there about supporting the staff
is so
valid um we've got as as organizations
we've got a massive
responsibility and duty to make sure
that our teams get through covid
you know as as much as importantly as us
as our
clients that we support do could i just
come back to you on that claire please
yes certainly phil um yeah it doesn't
sound as though the government or
people far away have much to do with
your
sense of feeling held and supported
no no i don't think no no no probably
not to be honest i think you know
um there's a lot there's a lot of
emergency funding out there for covered
that we've been able to access
and that has allowed us to think
differently so you know we've been able
to use that funding differently and
offered something like say some of the
diva days we've been allowed to to look
at the psycho you know changing from
group supervision so
there the funding is there but i don't
think it's specifically around
you know the um the compassionate
thinking around our teams it's around
as in you know as organizations we've
had to take that responsibility
okay yeah and can i just answer that i
think clay you summed up brilliantly
some of the stuff you're doing and i'd
like to mirror that so
we are fortunate i'm not always very
rarely actually do i say that we're
fortunate to be part of a national
organization but actually when it comes
to supporting and wellness
well-being of workforce it's actually
really um citizens of ice national team
have been
being great so there's quite a lot of um
support available for our workforce our
staff and our volunteers and a lot of
our volunteers
come into the offices because they want
to meet other people that's part of
volunteering isn't it they want to help
local people but they also want to be
part of a team
so we've had to put a lot of work into
our volunteers and
thinking about their their well-being
during this period some of them
elderly some of them shielding so we've
had to do a lot there
and also like claire some of the more
light touch things like um
you know we have a book club that we
haven't had before and we also tried to
sing
club but it was horrendous over zoom so
it only lasted two sessions and then we
just
decided it was awful it's more like the
cat's choir but
these these things i think we all
thought at the beginning
of lockdown that homeworking was uh
going to be a
perfect thing and was going to be full
of efficiencies and we'd carry on doing
it forever
and then after a couple of weeks we
realized that it wasn't it wasn't that
and
yes there are some efficiencies to home
working or remote working
but actually people want to come
together and be uh have physical
presence as
a team and some of those things that
claire was saying about complex issues
what we recognize is our teams would
talk about those over a cup of tea
or you know a biscuit between between
clients and when you're
working remotely from home on a laptop
you just can't do that
so it's about recognizing it but but as
claire said and
you know to answer your question i don't
think there's any national government
steer about workplace
wellness per se i think it's things that
we've sort of learned and
adapted ourselves over the covid um
situation and actually stuff that we
should carry on
doing post code because it's all very
useful and helpful and good for our
teams to do so thank you vicky
and i think just from tts tcps's
perspective
um and really quickly we operate a bit
of a middle ground because we're a
member of a body which represents um
volunteer
um center services nationally so we're
kind of we we do have a seat at table of
government but it's a very long table
and we're
right down the bottom but but we do get
some support coming out of it and one of
the the ones that i mentioned earlier
was the kovic jab
but that mental health and that welfare
issue of our staff and i think we all
feel exactly the same way it's really
critical so
actually we have a board meeting with
our trustees um
in mid-february and i've been working
certainly for the last six months in
looking at introducing an employee an
eap
program for our staff so that we can
ensure that they have that support
whether it be
counselling psychological uh debt
management we
we've got that kind of within our
organization to give because
what i've seen over the year over the
last 12 months is that welfare piece
and people come close to breaking at the
seams you know and and
just like um vicky and claire i've i've
pitched ourselves we are a caring and
compassionate employer
and we will bend over backwards for our
staff um so it really is high on our
agenda to to make sure that we've got
all the
processes in place thank you darren
thank you chair
thank you phil yeah i see no other blue
hands i just got a couple of cross
uh questions i i'm not cross question
but
cross-cutting questions i like to ask um
christopher hudson
actually said the word the client is
king and one of the questions i always
have and this
comes back to um our council tax support
scheme
i'm always surprised how little take-up
we seem to get on it
and then i did some checks and i found
that going through age uk
pensioners miss 3.5 billion pounds worth
of
pension credit and housing benefit and
that
if i translate that into torridge
numbers is about
four million pounds a year
how and who would be best to actually
challenge
uh um benefit taker and
point people in the right direction i
understand pension credit
is only about 70 percent take up um
and if you don't get pension credit you
don't get passported to council tax
benefit or
housing benefit so can or do you
actually check everybody or your clients
that they're getting
or they are entitled to can i come in on
that one then council of hunting so
i think from a citizen's advice
perspective when the client hits us we
like to think that we are
um we are covering that in terms of the
full benefit welfare benefit check
and we we try to do that um wherever we
can
um i suppose for us the difficulty would
be in those people that aren't coming to
us
so they don't recognize that they have
that they can claim or they're too proud
to claim
you know it's how do we get the message
out so what we have done in the past
with councils is a
benefits um a welfare benefits um
you know sort of campaign to to just
give people the
sort of knowledge and education around
the fact that these benefits
are there so we'd be absolutely happy to
have a conversation about doing
something locally in toronto about
benefits campaigns
thank you darren or
or claire do you want to add the comment
to that
yeah so i think um when we sort of
talked about our financial inclusion
project it is really targeted at
um some of the the older um
members of our community um and
we get referrals for a number of
agencies number of organizations you
know
from as far as field as the fire service
you know through to our projects not on
our colleagues
on online today so we will always do
that assessment and i think but our
at the moment we only operate at that
project within the biddeford
area it doesn't go as wide as torridge
um at this point in time
you know and i all i can say is you know
our kind of headline figure which i'm
always love saying i'm very proud of
is you know over 12 month period we've
filled that or we've plugged that gap by
quarter of a million pounds so
so actually that rings quite true to to
kind of your assessment of what
the impact is over torridge um certainly
we've had conversations um very recently
um
and i've been talking the wise money
today he spoke to to um
vicki um earlier on um in the week
looking at actually
you know how can we work better together
and make sure that you know we
complement each other and we're not kind
of crossing onto each other's territory
so
there's a bit of work there for us as
organizations but we're
well ahead of the curve on kind of
recognizing that and making sure we're
well positioned to tackle it yeah
and i guess yeah from encompassing wiser
money we would
um you know support any campaign in in
terms of that
um we do very much like what uh vicky
has alluded to you know everybody that
comes to us
do get a full benefit check but
absolutely how do we access those people
that don't
um so come in that's right there's a
pride somewhere along the way that stops
people coming in and
the the availability is there um but
they're
not taking up what is is is their
entitlement and
i find that quite surprising because
once you get a uh income support based
benefit
or income-based benefit your passport
into other help like council tax and
housing benefit
that makes a difference and the second
one is
is about social care
huge lot of problems going on at the
present moment particularly in their
care homes
um a lot of families now struggling and
um with the whole situation wanted to
bring their families back again
which is the best organization you would
recommend
for people who would want advice about
um options about care and
caring for family members bringing
people out of care homes may be
um who is the best organization to
represent
would it be devon carers or or would you
recommend going through your
organizations because there is so much
concern i
saw a statistic that um
[Music]
i think is 23 percent of of all care
home residents have passed away with
covert
diagnosis but only one less than one
percent of the national population
live in care homes which is quite a
frightening situation
and people have been just into that so
where would people go to get that advice
in social care can you
one of you pick up that answer i would
appreciate if you could please
um there's nowhere that springs to mind
i mean i'm looking at vicki and darren
yeah i was i was just going to stay off
the top of my head without
sort of having a bit more time to really
think about that i would say devon cares
would be the first
um the first place that one would
look to to go for it for advice on that
um but again it's down to the individual
isn't it and why they would
be wanting to take that person away you
know what that individual circumstance
is really
yeah we think devon carers is probably
the best place to start with that
okay direct i mean you've got care
direct manage
a lot of that so on behalf of social
care so i do wonder whether there is
um something there and i can certainly
ask the question at devon county council
level in terms of who
is there somewhere through care directs
that could support that
i don't know the answer but i can i'm
happy to
um okay thank you i'm glad you brought
that up claire i was going to say care
direct myself
um they seem to be a pretty good
one-stop shop for that sort of thing
and they can sign post you to many
organizations that could be yeah
incredible value now just linking to
that
um if i go back a few years ago there
used to be a little booklet that
produced by i think it was devon county
council
that listed all the organizations is
there such a booklet still around where
people have got
access to this information um
i know the younger generation are now on
to smartphones and all the rest
but particularly our aging generation
are not so much computer savvy would
would benefit from a booklet or
something or rather they would advertise
it
is there such a booklet still being
produced anywhere
as far as i'm aware there isn't and i i
fear that if there was one it would be
out of date as soon as it was printed
potentially why it's gone digital and
even the digital
um i think it was damn wasn't it devon
advice
network so there were various um things
that dcc were doing to try to pull
together all the different agencies and
stuff and
um you know i think actually local is
best in that in that sense there's
definitely one northern devon um around
sort of agencies that are out there to
support
so but but in answer to your question i
i don't know there isn't a
a as far as i'm aware and um probably
just a good
just as well in the sense um because
things are just changing so quickly
there isn't um that answers the question
there is online stuff yeah i i'm aware
of
yeah i'm aware of online what i i'm
concerned about is is the
exclusion that happens with some of the
um older members of our community that
was
what concerns me basically
um sheriff caller honking
um yeah i was just wondering what the
different organizations
would like from torridge district
council what can we do to help
in various ways or the councillors as
well
as the council
um presenters
um from our perspective we you know we
work really close with toys
council and i think you know we get a
lot of support um
and you know i think you know we're
really really grateful for that i think
you know it's fantastic so
um i think you know you guys are yeah
really
we're working really closely with you
there's nothing you know as i sit here
now going oh god that would be
really great you know i think as and
when things come up we tend to put it
through our main contact which is around
housing
um and yeah i think just for me it's
just making sure that we can continue to
have those kind of honest and
transparent conversations
and work really closely with you guys
and and it does feel i have to say
you know it it doesn't feel like them
and us which sometimes it does for
councils
you know account you've got the council
there's a power thing between council
and voluntary sector
i have to say in torch that's not there
it's really open and transparent and
um yeah which is great and i think you
know what i would say just more of that
please it's wonderful
yeah just just we've got an excellent
sorry vicky we've got an excellent
relationship there are many people
within tourist district council that
i can and do pick the phone up too
regularly and speak um there
are any um obvious gaps that i could
think of sitting here
okay thank you yeah and i would decode
that as to it certainly from an
operational perspective it works very
well
um from a sort of counsellor perspective
i guess it's um you know if you've got
if you've got
things that you want to talk to to any
of us about but you know in a particular
in the particular area that you're
working in the halls that you're
covering with
more than happy to pick that up and work
with you locally and i think
you know i guess we'll be bold and say
that you know continue
continue funding us that would be great
because you know demand is an issue
and resources are an issue and we we
need to put more resources in up from
what we're hearing from all three
agencies you know
we need to put more more resources on
the front line so
um continue to when you're having those
difficult funding you know who are we
going to fund conversations then please
um you know do everything you can to to
continue funding these agencies
thank you kirsten clark
it's me okay um just to let everybody
know
if they can see that but i don't know i
am a carer
so for a disabled wife
and it comes under devon carers and so
they do have a booklet i don't know if
you can see it
on the screen um and i have a phone
number
care direct which is um if you want me
to
tell you it you can write it down
councillor pennington
thank you very much yes it's three
four five one
five five one zero zero
seven and um
they'll they they'll give you
information and they'll supply you with
a booklet
and it gives all of the agencies in here
for all sorts of things and it also
can direct you to the other side of the
agency which is i think it's called
i'm sure janet will um tell me off now
um it's uh i think it's called
devon care director something where they
they come into your home
and assess your needs for
the person that's um requiring help
i mean my wife got a shower sorted out
and helped with it with railings around
the house and all sorts of stuff
to make the home more safe
for the person living in the home
and i've had great success in my ward i
have to say
with ward members that have required
this help
and we've had stannis stairlifts put in
and all sorts of stuff and they've been
um bath lifts all sorts of things that
can help
especially the elderly to stay in their
homes rather than go into a care home
so you know um it's something to think
about
and generally janet williams is the
person to speak to on this i think
you'll find
thank you very much i've got the
telephone number and
i'll take that away and work on that one
right
there's no further hands um i
want to again thank the speakers for
their presentation and thank all of you
for your contributions
is there any pressing recommendations
anybody would want to make
now that we do to come to conclusion of
the discussion we've had
obviously it seems like there was a
strong feeling that of closer working
together to make sure there was no
overlap
is um that was a clear message coming
through any other messages coming
through
stand from phil topham phil topham
uh yes thank you chad well i think that
we we should continue to press central
government to
support through their funding these
frontline
agencies because we are
very much now in a kind of if not
victorian then a kind of pre-welfare
state
situation where we depend on charity and
philanthropy
and i wonder under present circumstances
how long that can really continue
without more help for the center and
that's that's not disallowing the value
of the money that the government has
given recently but i'm thinking longer
term as well
but would you would you like to
recommend make a word
recommendation because uh i take it
these agencies are are funded by various
organizations that are both district
council county and uh national level and
those side organizations
but from a tourist district point of
view um we are we are
the uh external ons committee over
scrutiny committee for torridge
would you like a recommendation to make
a recommendation
a proposal sorry that um we continue the
funding in the same way
um for these organizations
yes but you you you raise the issue
about a possible recommendation there
i will try and get it right first time
because if i'm asked to repeat it
i might not remember it but i would like
to propose that
notwithstanding the more local sources
of funding that we
we do write to whether it's our
local mps or appropriate departments in
central government to encourage them
to support levels of county and district
funding for these voluntary services
well that is a very straightforward uh
proposal is there a second there
because the leather yeah chad don't we
don't we make we don't we don't write
directly to the government do it from
this committee we make recommendations
either to full council or cnr i just
appreciate that's what we
we we as our role as torridge do but um
i would obviously trying to
seek out a a proposal here um
and then phil topham our independent
member would like
specifically to focus on central
government through our mps
by his motion um and i hear what you're
saying prince of another equally
because our role is district council
level
and influencing our cnr but there is a
proposal there from
um phil topham and i just wondered if
there was
a second or from that point of view to
write to our mps
um and central government i think phil
topham's word
words were um um and if there was a
second or that proposal motion
chris we can come back to your s uh
chris leather we can come back to your
proposal in a second
if we wish to i second that
phil so your second phil topham's motion
counselor
can you mary can you just read out the
motion please
yes that we write to the local mp
or central government to encourage them
to support levels that count
of county and district funding for these
voluntary services
then there is the proposal um
we can we put up the vote do you agree
that we said
this isn't a proposal though that
council
write to our mp so
it is a proposal being put to
council or through cnr whichever route
you want
as opposed to nobody from in the name of
this committee is suggesting that we're
going to fire off a letter direct from
the committee
can i have clarity stacy on who we can
fire letters to
this committee because we're not making
a spending decision i i take that we
could actually as a committee right to
our mp
yeah if we're committing the council
then yeah it would have to be go to full
council for them to approve that
recommendation
um yeah if it's
from um full council i mean i
i guess councillor pennington you could
write
in your own right as chair as ons but it
wouldn't necessarily be on behalf of
torridge council
just that that you are you've had this
presentation
today you're the chair of the ons and
you would very much
welcome that so it's really how you
prefer to proceed
on my own position here um if the
committee doesn't want to write then i
would not write as chair of committee i
would write as phil
pennington ward member for monkey and
putford um
about the issue and not if there's not
support from the committee
so so um the situation go back to be
clear about
councillor uh independent member phil
topham's proposal
is that um it is to go for central
government um
and to the local mp um that
then that needs to go for ratification
through full council as i understand
those states of the situation
um and that's what we'll be voting on
so can we have a vote those in favor
do we have to go through individually i
take it we do
stacy yes chair and murray we'll we'll
we'll read um each counselor's name
very well chair can i just
just be clear then it's as i said that
we
will recommend either to full council
because we can recommend direct to full
council
[Music]
they're right our recommendation is they
write
to our mp and and to the government
yeah that's been added in now
let's be clear that's that's the
recommendation that that we
write to our full council that they
write to the
mp and the government
to continue funding to support and uh
um that is what we're voting on is that
clear are you agreeing with that phil
topham and shirley
langford yeah yeah
okay so you have that
proposal and you have the secondary
we go to the vote for mary please okay
cancel a cuddle honking
councillor ford four
council heart thing four
councillor hawkins four
councillor langford four
councillor leather or
councillor mckenzie for
council newton for
councillor pennington or
unanimous thank you
one that's painful in the end sorry
because i missed your comment i just say
wasn't that painful in the end you see
sorry carry on okay fine is there any
other recommendations
that to any coaches who has chair connor
hunken first of all please
um yeah i was thinking of
recommendations to
cnr and or full council when considering
the budget
um about continuing funding
so we fund ttvs and cab
that's right isn't it but not income yes
come
stacy we we and janet um
we don't fund in compass do we as i
understand it
yeah we work alongside encompass and
encompass are assisting us
um with some of our schemes um such as
the hardship scheme so we
we make a donation it's not a donation
that they're doing our admin work for
them so
i don't think we specifically fund um
encompass but
in terms of making a referral to cnr i
mean
this we've got cnr on the 1st of
february in the budget reports with
with that already um so um
the recommendations are are within that
so i don't think it would be necessary
to make a separate recommendation today
in relation to the funding there's no
indication
that any of that's going to change at
present
did we just put forward that we
recognized a huge positive impact
on the residents of torridge not only
financially but also in terms of
well-being and um
can i just say if there was an
indication that anything the funding was
going to change and there would be a
full officer report
dealing with those sorts of issues but
there's no indication at present so i
don't think
um i'm not sure if the cnr report has
been published i think it's due to be
published on friday but there's
certainly
um no indications or changing of the
funding
okay as as chair of the committee then
um
and not having seen what's actually in
the budget
and having some previous discussions
over the last
uh week i suppose um i certainly would
want to have something from this meeting
that emphasizes
what sort of proposal that councilor
called hunk
was making um so i i just
um i feel safer from that point of view
this committee has had this discussion
um and we we have looked at the proposal
if the committee still decides not to
follow it through
that's the committee's choice now when
they come to the vote in a minute but if
i would certainly second counselor
caller honkin to make the recommendation
that she was previously recommending
and i wondered if she would go back into
that situation and make her proposal
again
that we were opposed to the budget or
the cnr meeting
that we we feel the true value in the
ish the
continuing funding should be supported
yeah i'd be happy
to do that i don't think we'd we'd lose
anything by doing that
um also councillor newton was asking
um some of the organizations about
how much they well whether we need to
increase
or how much do they need maybe we could
look at that in the future
well we leave it just we're now looking
just purely just to come to a conclusion
and a recommendation here so your
proposal is
that we recommend do to full council um
and the budget setting
that can funding has continued to both
the tpvs
and citizen's advice yeah that keeps it
simple
yeah your recommendation
yeah are you a proposal i will second
that
and i will take it to the vote
zero
um again suddenly it's needed
council organs well if it's not needed
why
why don't yeah anyway okay yeah i'm for
that
council langford or
cancel a leather line against because
it's already
in the budget i have not seen another
councilor mckenzie
councillor newton likewise i'm against
it because it
it's in the budget as we understand it
and secondly
the the presentations that we've had
this evening
weren't designed around us being able to
scrutinize
value for money or indeed assessing
the impact within the community because
uh we did
we haven't had the type of facts and
figures that we would need
to exercise proper scrutiny so therefore
i'm not against what's been said but as
a result i don't think
we're in a position to actually make
this statement because we haven't seen
the figures
um because we didn't ask for them
probably um and that's fair enough but
um
so as such i'm not able to support him
okay are you abstaining uh country
newton or are you again
yeah that thank you for that advice yes
i would like to abstain rather than vote
against yes
thank you newton mancella pennington
councillor
against and one abstention
thank you very much mary any other
uh cousin mckenzie your hands up here
for
um i was work oh yeah i am not muted i
was wondering if there's anything we
could do as a committee to influence
um housing um it was said by
um encompass um that you know how
people want their own front doors etc
etc i mean i know
we've got um targets and quotas around
affordable housing and stuff
but in particular we need sort of like
um
you know houses with with a single
bedroom and stuff there doesn't seem to
be much of that being built um i don't
know if we could um
somehow influence it from this committee
the steer the
the um district council into
putting provision in somewhere or indeed
building ourselves with a
small works loan or whatever if that's
appropriate but
you know we're in a housing crisis and
we need to do something i'm not sure
what i'm getting at or how we how we do
it um
i'm sure people put a friend on you mr
pennington yeah no not at all i
thank you coach mckenzie i just wonder
can i suggest
that you you're just going away from the
very pacific looking at the encompass
ttvs and this
advice here um um and
it is it's about these three
organizations just at the moment i know
housing is
is huge comments from the from the
encompass
um around you know um clients having a
door and you know the lack of provision
for
for them you know that they're
struggling to provide what they
do um you know they'll we obviously need
we've got a
an obligation haven't we to safeguard
our vulnerable
in the society and you know i think that
we do it
better then then briefly without long
discussions
can you put a motion that is reflective
of tonight's discussion
that you could call less around that we
could we we could i
agree and there needs to be a short
pithy recommendation
uh proposal uh coaster mackenzie and i
don't want to
make it too long but but it has to be
focused and
i hear what you say and if there's
support then i will go with it
oh goodness that's it on the spot um i
think i suppose it'd have to be
something along the lines of um that we
propose
a debate at full council to provide
housing provision for the most
vulnerable
um supporting our our partner agencies
does that sound fair yeah have you have
you got that one mary
did you get that yeah sorry i can't put
my hand up for something i don't i don't
have the
option um but just to explain that there
is
um and councillor clark will will be um
in on this meeting but there there is a
proposal regarding a
housing strategy coming through um
and the working groups just being formed
so it's part of a much bigger
bigger piece of work um helen page who
i'm sure will be happy um
wants to come along to ons um works on
this sort of stuff
um frequently um and we do team up
with um agencies like encompass
um so it's it's part of a much bigger
piece of work that's already ongoing
um so i'm just trying to prevent another
notice of motion on a similar matter
coming through
um i'd like to withdraw my uh proposal
because
um double duplicate work it's already
been done i swear that i was unaware of
thank you so much very happy it's still
in the early stages it's in relation to
a previous notice of motion that that
was put forward
um because it's a matter that members
have raised
you know on numerous occasions so it is
the wheels are in motion for
it excellent have you
you've withdrawn your emotion i take it
so that yeah
thank you for your clarity uh counselor
i just very quickly i wanted to endorse
i was
had my hand up because i was going to
say exactly what stacy said
it's part of our strategy uh that has
been approved
going forward for the next five years
that we do
look at the
delivery of affordable housing through
various methodologies
to provide additional accommodation so
yes this working group is going and it's
going to happen
the working group is going to go forward
not in months time
but quite soon that they're going to
have their initial meeting
so just to confirm that thank you very
much indeed
right i don't see any further blue hands
here so i
conclude the end of these discussions
um we've made our recommendations
i thank all of you uh particularly
claire
uh vicky and darren for their
contributions their work
their teams that they come from um
and we wish you well and what support we
can give as a council
we and look forward to working with you
in your future thank you so much for
what you've done this evening
with that we enjoy the opportunity
sorry thank you for the opportunity
thank you for the opportunity
thank you darren good night um to
uh thank you for your opportunity you're
welcome to stay with us um
um as we go on um we've got uh further
agenda item to do
um so we go forward to agenda item
number
11 and uh it's a lead member update
to keep us paced with what's happening
um from health and well-being regard to
the coronavirus
and the many questions that some of our
residents may be having so i call on
phil hackett to give us a brief variable
update on
the health and well-being issue on the
coronavirus at the present moment
thank you chair thank you phillip um
good evening committee
um i shall be brief and i'm not going to
go into too much detail on statistics
which are readily available on
both websites and on the television
every night
the health protection board continues to
meet weekly chair by steve
brown the new director of public health
who replaced virginia pearson
the stats and updates from this are then
disseminated through various regional
and local meetings
which means that information sent out to
partners and agencies
is updated regularly to summarize where
we are this week
local rates are still lower than what's
being seen nationally
while there are reductions in rates
being seen in some areas of the country
at the moment we're just seeing a
leveling off
which mirrors our general position being
two or three weeks
behind the national trend we're hoping
this pattern will continue and that will
be
seeing a reduction of infections rage
shortly
especially as the effects of lockdown
start to show
i remind members that you can look on
the devon.gov
dot uk slash corona
advice in devon slash corona data
and these are the statistics for today
that i see before me we've got 52 cases
in the last week
which represents around 76.2 per hundred
thousand of our residents
now there are a number of high-profile
programs being undertaken at present
and this is just a brief outline firstly
vaccinations
there are several strands to this all in
place and developing
all the time these are hospital-based
vaccinations
primary care network program mass
vaccination centers
west point in exeter and one in plymouth
both due to come
online next week and there's a fixed
vaccination site
in barnstable and there's a roving
vaccination program
in addition to that we've got a pharmacy
vaccination program
at our westwood hose site and i remember
and i remind members that
about 50 of our population of torridge
is living north of biddeford town hall
ultimately the plan is for no one to be
more than 10 miles from a vaccination
site
with the roving sites being utilized in
rural areas
tourist district council has been
working closely with arnold's pharmacy
in westwood home
in supporting their site and that should
be coming online next week
they'll be operating an 8 to 8 7 days a
week
with up to 500 vaccinations a day
so this is a significant site for
torridge
vaccination data is being published
online
and is being refined it should be it
should
soon be showing a breakdown of
vaccinations area
and type in the meantime
the information can be readily sourced
at www.england.nhs.uk
statistics slash statistical work areas
covid 19 vaccinations the priorities for
testing
are nationally mandated and are
currently all residents in care homes
for old adults
and their carers all those 80 years of
age and over
and front line health and social care
workers
all those 75 year olds of age and over
all those 70 year olds of age and over
and clinically extremely vulnerable
individuals
i understand that we are looking to
complete these priorities by the end of
february
members will hopefully appreciate that
national news
and mandates are constantly changing in
this area
with plenty of calls for other groups to
be put
further up the list we have no influence
on this prioritization process
community testing this is a devon county
council-led program
and it's still in its early days of
development and presentations are being
made
this week to the hpb and the cx group
community testing will help to find
individuals
who have covid19 but do not have
symptoms
and need to isolate and who may be
inadvertently be spreading the virus
to understand the demand for the program
organizations and employees who have
staff and workers who
be eligible for testing are encouraged
to register their details
and that can be found at a
link from forms dot office dot com
slash pages slash response page
you can usually send those links to
mary i am going to send this to mary
yes yes i'm just reading it into the
evidence
and then there's the enhanced track and
trace finally
in addition the dem county council
have also just embarked on enhanced
track and trace programme
which really support or supplant the
national track and trace program
this is very much under development at
present and we have no further details
what this will look like locally
and what the ask will be on district
authorities
we're just going to have to field any
queries coming
out of your update
um that i've given tonight
um the problem is that announcements are
being made by central government
and things appear in the news which we
as a district council
have no prior knowledge or additional
information
about such as the school's testing
program
so that's all i'm going to update you
with tonight councillors
um i will send this on to mary for
dissemination
thank you very much thank you any
questions there is a question from
coaster hudson
right it's really an observation uh many
questions from
uh local constituents about the progress
of being selected
for vaccination um
representatives of who've got parents
over 80 that haven't been called yet
and why was it happening so slowly
locally
the response it was actually mentioned
in a news broadcast
yesterday on the bbc one has to consider
the demographics of the area
we have a very high percentage
of people in later years
in our area so therefore it will take
a little longer to work through that
cohort
than somewhere where they have only a
very low percentage
of people over 80. so that's the
reassurance
i'm giving people and i think
facebook again sometimes is good because
they do
say yes my my granny's been sent to
barnstable for the vaccination
but just to reassure people that their
turn
will come and once arnold says
phil has just said i've got westwood her
up and running which is expected to be
saturday
of this week we should start moving a
bit more quickly
hopefully locally thank you thank you
thank you councillor hackett
north blue hands do we move on then to
agenda item 12
and i put in homelessness there because
of
the situation the ending of
mortgage holidays and rent holidays and
the possible impacts of what we're
facing in our fast chrysler clark
just to give us a verbal update of the
situation as well um
i think we might have discussed a lot of
it in the previous meeting but i think
christopher clark's got a lot to bring
to us as well so chrysler clark
he's for agenda item 12. i'm going to
keep mine quite
brief actually so that'll help you uh
firstly i want to bring you some numbers
we had a meeting last week with janet
and
helen page from housing options who's
the manager now
and um the number of approaches
that triggered a homeless response
from april to november was 559
which was down on the previous year
um the total that had
a good outcome actions taken were 309
so those that had to that had to have an
action taken
were 309 so
that was okay um the people in temporary
accommodation at the moment
we've got 13 hostels or 13 in hostels
should i say
pier cells we've got five woodbury
one golden bay we've got
five other spot purchases which is like
bed and breakfast and so on
we've got five which gives us a total of
29
that's of the 13th of the first 21
so that's only last week so that's where
we stand
last week as of november
2019
we had 62 successful outcomes
as of november 20
we had 68 of successful
outcomes so we're improving
in this department
now the other information we're dealing
with at the moment we're trying to put
together some um
outreach programs where we're speaking
to
uh in compass so it's nice to see them
this evening
um and also
we're dealing with elaborate on
a floating support basis
and one of our major problems coming up
is the 18 plus which is
a district county council funded program
that's going to end in february
so we're going to have we we're trying
to get other monies in but
um that's one that's going to come up
become a problem
going forward and the other issue that i
had
i'd like to speak on and perhaps
anybody's got any advice on going
forward is
when um we are released if you like
from covid which is you know hopefully
in a couple of months time
we those people that we are supporting
in golden bay
woodbury and places like that
we've got to make a decision because um
obviously golden bay braddocks and
places like that
will want their their units back
to rent out for the summer season as
tourist resorts
and of course we will have then a
homeless problem
because these people effectively will be
made again homeless and so we need a
strategy
in place so that if they're coming out
of there we have
um accommodation available
whether it be temporary or
semi-permanent or permanent
to put them in because otherwise you
know
there's there's there's the there's the
problem
and some of them could be young people
under 25 you know so
there's lots of little issues coming up
we have
um helen page and myself and janet
we're trying to put together several
workshops
so that we can talk with different
agencies
around um sofa surfing
and uh you know as uh
council mckenzie said with domestic
violence
these are things that we're trying to
look ahead at and speak to the right
agencies so that we can try and put some
policies in place
to cover these areas
so this is where we're at with it's an
ongoing situation i have to say we had
our first meeting uh
last week to lay out some groundwork and
give me some figures and i've got loads
of figures trust me i mean helen's great
at
producing figures but i didn't want to
bombard you with loads of figures
tonight
um we are dealing with the problem
but it's going to take time because we
want to speak to all the different
agents
and i'll leave it there if that's right
any questions yes please i would if i
can yeah michael um
just on when you were talking there
about um
having to uh give back or give up
uh holiday accommodation once that
becomes um
once we're free from cavite as you put
it
just to quantify it for us so we've got
a so i've got a better idea what sort of
numbers are we talking about at the
moment
um i can tell you we have
i would think it's not a great deal i
mean you're talking
we've got 29 at the moment um
13 of those are in hostels at the moment
so
you're talking about 16 16 people at the
moment
so it's not it's not a great deal of
people because
the way torridge is you know um
and our team that helen page runs is
is really on the ball i have to say
we're getting things sorted
that um we don't have a major problem i
mean north devon have a much bigger
problem than we'll ever have
you know as regards homelessness i mean
i've worked in it
that side of it for so many years
that um you know freedom and holy
trinity and at the salvation army that
i've
you know i was one of the originals 26
years ago
at bpag you know so i go back a long way
with this um and uh
you know it's not it's not going to be
drastic but it's it's there
we don't have housing stock
one of our strategies at the moment at
this moment
not you know going forward this is what
we're trying to deal with now
is trying to engage with private
landlords to try and encourage them
to let torridge put place
people there and of course the people
we're placing
um have had issues in the past
you know with not paying their rent on
time and stuff like that and
it's one of those things and as it was
pointed out earlier on in our
discussions this evening
this is where we're at but that
all could change if once we're out of
this landlord start to kick out their
tenants because they haven't been paying
rent
and that's that's that that's that's an
unknown factor
nobody knows you know i i encourage
and i encourage all of the councillors
to when they're speaking to their parish
councils
to try and encourage their parish
council to find out if anybody in their
community is struggling to speak to
people now
yes speak to citizens advice speak to
encompass speak to ttvs
and speak to torridge you know speak to
our
housing options team and say look i'm
about to be made homeless
there are michael
oh sorry yeah can i just ask you i mean
follow
from simon's question i simon might want
to come back in a minute as well
i mean there's a lot of figures and all
the rest of it i and and
i want a sort of a gut reaction if you
like
i mean when the mortgage holiday ends
and given the changes for holiday
accommodation having to be re-let to
holiday makers
is the problem and you're feeling going
to be twice as bad or
three times as bad or not as bad at all
when when the holiday period ends for
mortgage and rent arrears
it's an unknown it's an unknown quantity
i mean
it could be it could be drastic but if
people
speak early enough you know
we have we have a good team at torres
that can speak to landlords on their
behalf perhaps come up with a plan
a repayment package you know it's not if
if the landlord kicks out a tenant
they've lost that money if they speak to
us
and we can come up with some sort of
repayment package
a we're not making that person homeless
and b we're we're resolving a problem
where um we're trying to help the
landlord recuperate
his money i i can't say about mortgage
people because
they are a different entity that i'm not
i'm not qualified to speak on really i
have to say
but the key is you're saying michael get
your residents anybody that you know in
your wards to talk
quickly to the people i mean if you bury
your head in the sand
you're sunk if you if you are
may if you make yourself intentionally
homeless
we can't help you legally if you make
yourself intentionally homeless
i want to end the meeting before three
hours i still got the minutes to go
through
i should have been in a parish council
meeting about an hour and a half ago so
if anybody's got any more questions then
i'm going to disappear and try and catch
the town end of the parish council
okay okay uh any questions
claire claire hodson right very quickly
um with the drive that you are saying
that helen's looking at
for additional private sector lease
properties
as you say you only have five at the
moment
um are you exploring working in
partnership with encompass
to give some of these more challenging
clients that you have
housed in holiday accommodation um
the reassurance for landlords that the
clients will be supported
uh all i can all i can answer that on
claire is i hope so
i mean um i've not had that conversation
myself
with um helen yet
but we are over the next few weeks
trying to put
some things together to to sit down with
encompass
sit down with the laboratory and sit
down with a couple of other agencies
that we
that we use put things in place
going forward i mean you're on the case
because private sector landlords do tend
to work better
if they know there is going to be
support for the tenants
going in yeah we need you for that it is
as they spoke as those people spoke
earlier
guys i want to try and um um
uh cover various points there uh first
of all
cursor langford very quickly yes thank
you it sort of relates to this
i just want to say that um i haven't got
a magic answer to that or anything but
um
just that i i found it very encouraging
to hear from
those three voluntary agencies you know
how well they felt
they were supported by torridge and how
well they worked with torrid so um
thank you to everyone involved in that
congratulations to the officers really
thank you thank you shirley uh
officer jonas janet williams please
uh chair i just wanted to uh reassure
council austin that we are working very
closely with encompass on some of our
more challenging clients and they have
been an absolutely fantastic agency
providing
support there's also um you know debt
management support all
range of things various and programs
and that have been mentioned like floor
and where we
were that that team around the person
really is being put
in place it's in everybody's interest to
try and create
a sustainable home and for for
our clients and so that you know the the
they stay where they are they're happy
and they're not
um coming back to the agencies and
causing repeat issues so we are
we are working very closely with those
agencies thank you janet
i appreciate that um thank you michael
for your presentation
and enjoy hi pickington anything else
you want to add
briefly no i'm fine i'm going to
disappear and go to
robert parish council now and get the
tail end of their meeting
thank you for your presentation michael
yes
cheers now right now we go back guys
and we're back to agenda item number two
uh minutes uh pages 3 to 21 we've got
two sets of minutes here
to approve and we're going to start and
um
for just for accuracy first of all any
on pages on the sorry the
meeting of wednesday the 18th of
november for accuracy
and now you're on your agenda page three
four five 6
7
8 9 10
and 11 anything arising from them
nothing good then we go forward to the
meeting of the
wednesday the 25th of november um
we then go from page 12. 13
14 15
16 17
18 19 20 21
no blue hands any matters arising one
that is counselor leather
no matters arising chair it's not an
agenda item
i want to move both sets of those
minutes please
you want to move them both sets
yeah i would second that so we have
poser and secondary
for um um uh proposing both sets of
minutes
and mary you can take two votes uh from
each councillor
on the situation please um
for the minutes proposed by councillor
leather
and seconded by councillor newton okay
councillor cottle hankin i i've just
noticed on the agenda it says
confirmation for minutes held on 18th of
november and 30th
but it's 25th isn't it that's on the
actual agenda
sorry yeah okay um
council langford ford both
council leather or
council mackenzie eight that's two fours
councillor newton uh four to base please
cancel pennington or play no four and
four
i missed the top em and four
thank you four that's you know mary i
take it yes it is yeah both sets
thank you councillors uh then we go to
agenda item number three action list
page 22 only one item on it which has
been done on the twenty
no the second of just let me get up
there completed
so that is all done uh thank you for
counsellor haynes
for that so that's completed so then it
leaves us for our last agenda item
first of all uh this last agenda item
which is
consideration of the floor plan agenda
item number 13.
so we have before cloud before us
first of all an apology from myself
because i did not
invite the uh to they said
of the today's meeting it was to include
health and mental health
um but given the width of this evening's
meeting
i decided that we tried to work towards
looking
to have a joint meeting with north devil
on health again in the previous way so
forgive me
um if you can as your chair um
for for uh having decided to have the
agenda gone that way i don't know if
anybody wants to take an issue with that
um we go forward then
i don't see any blue hands okay so we go
forward to the 10th of march
we still got westward housing i take it
janet
or stacy coming as far as i'm aware
they're aware have we heard anything um
back from our mp for the agricultural
build discussion
and the impact on agriculture
has anybody uh made any contact in that
direction
no that i think we need unless you want
to change that meeting for the
10th of march we still want to go
without i take it as a committee any any
blue hands in that direction
so i take it as a yes we're still going
with that
so therefore we need to contact the uh
mp to have that discussion um
and we've got the annual report to
discuss as well which is going to be
quite interesting from from this year
uh there was a note i think at the end
that we were going to this
end of the minutes of
the 18th just let me see what
uh there was a resultant resolve
no no no no no
[Music]
that's right yes right it was the end of
the minutes of the 25th of november
um the remit for the 10th of march to be
finalized at the january meeting
so i we i am recognizing what we said in
our minutes of the 25th
of uh november um we need to get hold of
the mp
and make some final decisions of what we
want from that meeting is there any
views
from the committee exactly where we're
going to to ask the mp and what we're
going to ask
mp when it comes if he comes
okay it's it's quite interesting because
i mean given the
interesting thing on the fishing
industry which
has been in the last few days
um i i just wonder what the impact
the culture given the various issues
around there
and there is a lot of questions coming
forward on that one
um but i think we need to think about
some of us
actually sitting down and scoping what
we want from that meeting
i don't know if anybody's interested i
got councillor hudson with the hand up
here as well
yeah it's just a bit of information that
the
chief exec the leader of the council
uh councillor james and myself meet with
the mp
um we have another meeting coming up at
the beginning of february
or second week in february um
so you know if if you are writing we
could actually
raise that issue about but i'm sure he
would want to know
why he was being uh asked to attend
and i think you would have to get
together to have an agenda
and whether you want to include
fisheries in that as well
as agriculture um whether that was
appropriate
far be it from me i'm not on your
committee no i think you contribute an
awful lot clara thank you for what you
say
um um
interesting about uh uh that we gotta
consider that christopher cottle honking
i think at the last meeting we said
about um
post-brexit issues in general and how it
would impact on residents in torridge
but maybe with a focus on agriculture
if i remember rightly i thought i don't
know if it was councillor top and
phil topham that said about post brexit
was that right there i can't remember uh
yeah i think that was absolutely right
cheryl yes indeed and and all the more
relevant now i think possibly
correct no then um with that are we
happy then that we continue with the uh
the invite to the mp
to come and see what he has to say and
we actually sit down and scope
some questions out about uh keeping it
to the impact of brexit as well as just
agriculture
um although it was agriculture was the
wish is that the wish of the committee
yeah yes anybody say no say
eyes have it as they say in westminster
so
yes a hand up there from phil topham
i just wonder whether it might be fair
to invite maybe the
the national farmers union who came
along last year
just to perhaps to give a bit of balance
i just wondered okay i mean if um
you're talking about is the fisherman
guys down in april
um leonard interested in doing anything
in this direction
um chair can you hear me i can hear you
yeah yeah yeah even though i i do go
along
uh obviously with um what shell was
saying because predominantly we are
an agricultural area but irrespective
although people voted uh brexit because
we're not
we mainers are leavers now are we
moaners we're all leaders we've
left however i think both sides told a
lot of
lies and they were actually just about
seeing some of the consequences
and it is already impacting us we've all
seen them over the last week with
fishermen in general
right now what i will say is to keep
this brief because we've only got
minutes left at nine o'clock
obviously april and biddeford are
predominantly very small trips
uh trawlers like sepna but there are
issues
even with weatherford down at the fish
key
transport in his official way they'll
not go away from the
and process at avador so there is an
impact and all of that should be
recognized
may be acknowledged and spoken about how
it may be getting better or what's going
to happen in the future
okay thank you so you're in favor of
inviting somebody a representative from
the fish
community well what i want to do is keep
this
brief because to be fair i think you
might find jeffrey
not it's too busy and he's no sir
you know i don't do titles so he's still
jeffrey to me
right but the bottom line is we need a
letter from him if we don't want to come
we need acknowledgement about the
seriousness
impacts and what the future hopefully is
going to be like because people do
deserve and
should have that oh by their mp
so are we as a committee going to invite
our mp as our previous wish
yes and are we going to then include
other uh allied industries and
interested parties to be invited to the
meeting
nfu has been uh mentioned but there
could be others that would have a lot of
interest
if they wish to yes yeah yeah
anybody sure that they are against that
going forward from there
so it would be invite those other
industries
just to invite them to speak to jeffrey
cox or
we wouldn't ask for a presentation or
anything like that
we would highlight it from a point of
view of the impact of brexit on our
indigenous industries basically which
um strange enough might be a bonus to
tourism because nobody's going to go
abroad ever again it seems like
to me it might be a negative to the
parking down at apple door later
from that point of view might be a
negative
on other industries so there's going to
be policies winners and losers
um and it's to ask her in mp on
his impression of the impact on all
those industries that are across
the district are you agreed to that
yes the pool ain't good
um from that point i think we also need
to set up a sk
a scooping if we have this wide ranging
sort of
discussion for the next meeting um
and looking at the time now uh can we do
it
in email around for those interested
to put some questions together and i
would suggest
three weeks before the meeting takes
place so we can send the questions off
to our mp to give them a fair chance to
do some research
uh about the answers we find if
you're interested theory now i certainly
would uh take part in that
um and we can have a meeting
uh to set those questions prior to the
meeting
yeah i'm in favor yeah yeah good
all in favor that's good i don't see any
blue hands against
is there anything else or anybody else
wants to say add or anything else
no good thank you for everything you've
done
thank you for your cooperation mary the
best of luck brexit must seem easy
compared to sorting out what's going on
this evening so thank you for you
thank you officers uh thank you
everybody and i bid you
good night on this 20th of january